ladies and gentlemen
the united states has been invaded by
chinese communist authoritarians and the
incoming president-elect
is compromised his son has accepted
money from
chinese communist connected individuals
and the incoming president actually flew
his son
on government property to china all of
that was true right
i'm pretty sure i got it right yeah air
force two they flew together
now as for the beginning part i'm joined
by china uncensored the host
you guys want to introduce yourselves
and then would you would you like to
fact check what i just said
i'm not certified by fact by facebook so
i don't really see that my excellent
then it must be true it must be
there we go so who are you guys i'm
chris chappell the host of china
uncensored and
i'm shelley jong the humor ninja of
china and sponsored
that's right i'm not funny without her
mm-hmm right on luke's also hanging out
we got luke caskey chilling over here
yep i have to say i am disappointed
angry and frustrated tim um
the emmys never got in contact with me
for my amazing acting yesterday
with your little arms and if andrew
cuomo could win an emmy
so can i anything could happen and also
specifically
thank you everyone who reached out to me
through venmo and cash app through luke
we are change i got like 500 bucks it
means a lot to me
thank you so much uh the community here
i have to say is utterly amazing and
super funny and i appreciate i
appreciate you guys
a lot thank you we got a lot to talk
about today of course we've got
sourpatch lids over producing
the corner pushing all um so
i opened by saying that the the united
states is being invaded by chinese
communist authoritarians
what are your thoughts well i did i
might have
suggested that yes exactly that's why i
said it yeah
yeah uh well i mean essentially that is
that is the big story that's how we kind
of um
found ourselves making a satirical show
about china news it's that
the chinese communist party is having a
tremendous uh influence in u.s
well the entire society in politics and
media and
uh local level to the federal level and
you know not a lot of people were
talking about it
when we started the show in 2012 uh it's
coming out now though
yeah so uh i've been i've been covering
quite a bit of news for a long time when
i was working for the company fusion in
2014.
they actually did cover a big story i
think this was the uh nicaraguan canal
are you guys familiar with the
nicaraguan canal oh yeah china was
essentially trying to bypass
the panama canal and it was a ridiculous
project that would have destroyed a
large freshwater aquifer and been very
very disastrous but ultimately
ultimately got abandoned so
there have been reporters i've seen who
have been tracking this stuff
but it's never making and as far as i've
seen the big headlines the front page of
the new york times
the things that are going on with china
buying property in all of these
different countries
but like they're buying up communities
in certain places owning all the land
and they're doing oil exploration in
africa south america they've got a ton
of influence with security services and
some
in the south american countries and it
seems like probably
i would say in my opinion the biggest
threat to the united states and probably
probably to what we would define as
liberal
democracy or you know constitutional
republic like the united states is
chinese communist subversion i mean i
think that's definitely true
and around the world every time we talk
to a
you know human rights activists from you
know from bolivia from cambodia from
mauritania yeah like they are always
talking about how china is
basically infiltrating their countries
paying off their dictators
um putting their countries in debt
taking all their national resources
so you know this is like very it's been
happening for years
and people are only starting to realize
it
now i think it might be too late uh it's
i don't think it is too late
um it's definitely it's definitely
getting close to being too late but it
really depends on uh just the general
american public
uh not just the american public but uh
in liberal democracies around the world
uh lebron james said china good
steve cartoon yeah yeah that's that's
lebron james is famous
he and he's actually really good he's
more famous than us
yeah that's right so he goes up there
and he tells all these people
nah chill it's cool china's all right
well no the nba has had a huge backlash
specifically this was one of the
major turning points i think in the past
like year or two of people becoming
aware
of uh the influence the chinese
communist party has
when uh houston rockets uh well the
general manager daryl mori
he like tweeted something in support of
like the protests happening in hong kong
huge nba somebody has like a four well
he tweeted free hong kong
yeah and like the nba has a huge
contract in china
four billion dollars is that about right
oh yeah
it's it's a lot yeah uh
and yeah so there there was talk of like
them firing him and uh there were even
like americans who went to basketball
games like holding like free hong kong
signs at once
i remember the americans yeah so this
was a case where like people saw oh wait
americans are being censored in america
because of what's happening
in china and so that was a big moment of
like you know maybe lebron james
maybe he doesn't know what he's talking
about the nba had a basketball camp
in xinjiang where the uyghurs were being
imprisoned
concentration camps
they only stopped that like a month or
two ago like this year
that like they had a partnership with a
chinese
you know organization that was doing a
basketball that's great they could have
waved to the uh mulan production
so also very interestingly there's some
reports coming out of australia that
nike that of course
hires lebron james and is almost going
to make him a billionaire
that they're you also using some uyghur
muslim slaves
in order to produce some of their
products sneakers and of course
also the mba jerseys that a lot of the
nba players wear
what do you make of these kind of
reports coming from australia
do you think they're legitimate and do
you think there's any credence behind
them well i think
i think one sad thing that does need to
be mentioned is that you have companies
like
apple and nike like actually lobbying
against
a bill going through congress right now
about
forced labor in china they don't want it
to pass
and this is the big issue you see that
you know if you treat
china like a country that has
concentration camps
you can't treat it like a normal country
yeah well you should all be
investing money and doing a lot of
business yeah it's great buy their bonds
don't buy their bonds um yeah i mean i
think the
it was in the australian strategic
policy institute that did that study
um and they're they did a lot of
research into this and it's pretty legit
like i don't think it's uh the chinese
communist party got really pissed off
about them publishing that like they're
basically
punishing australia right now with a big
trade war
and one of the things that they were mad
about was this particular think tank
talking about the uyghur stuff like they
had this like 14-point bulletin of the
things that australia has done
wrong and that was on the list didn't
the chinese government release
a fake video of allegedly an australian
soldier hurting a small afghanistan it
was a
photo is it a photo yeah it was it was a
propaganda poster
so i think it's safe to say that
relations between china and australia
aren't really the best right now
the funniest thing that happened
recently is the fact that they stopped
australian coal imports
as part of this trade war thing and now
there are several cities in china that
are running out of power
because they were dependent on these
unnecessary sacrifices
you know so now like there's reports
that they're like doing like rolling
blackout kind of things because they're
running out of power because they
like stop the australian cold because
they want to punish australia and they
shot themselves in the foot they're also
in a really
critical situation with food supplies
because they had unprecedented flooding
this summer that's right so they've been
importing more grain
than ever like it's up 30 from the
previous year
uh did the the floods were were hitting
wuhan right
uh yes you wuhan has had a very bad year
interesting
very bad of all the cities huh i suppose
there's other cities that had bad years
though in china so it's not well
yeah they've probably all had a pretty a
pretty bad year
yeah well let's let's let's jump to the
first big story uh before we do make
sure you guys
smash that like button and share this
video share the the podcast if you
really do think we're doing a good job
and uh you know help support the channel
but we have this uh breaking news coming
out of the state
department and i'll tell you the first
and the weirdest thing
nobody's written about this we were
sitting here waiting all day there's a
big announcement mike pompeo said
executive action
was coming later today it was going to
be big news and a lot of people were
wondering
would this be trump firing off that
executive order over
foreign election interference finally
taking control and
winning the election and uh no it's u.s
imposes sanctions on people's republic
of china actors
linked to malign activities so there's a
lot to do with mass surveillance
military modernization human rights
abuses
and the south china sea and it's about
sanctions against
specific members of the chinese
communist party who of course the state
department
trump's administration have been railing
against a whole lot so it's not
what a lot of trump's of peter's trump
supporters were crossing their fingers
for
but it is still pretty significant
action from the
the you know the latest actions we've
seen from the us government one of the
biggest impacts that i can
say will will hit you is that when you
go to best buy
and you want to get that fancy little
gimbal to film things with or you want a
drone
you ain't going to get it us government
adds dji to commerce blacklist over ties
to the chinese government
american companies will be forbidden
from exporting technology to the drone
maker so
perhaps we can still end up getting it
here it doesn't seem like it'd be
likely i don't know what do you guys
know about this what's going on with the
dji thing
i think it's generally they've been
added to this uh blacklist that means
that u.s companies can't
export technology to them so they can
still send it here then
yeah i think like huawei can still for
example sell phones in the us but they
just can't
you know buy u.s like semiconductor
chips that's kind of weird because i
it wasn't like par the part part of the
reason why we weren't buying technology
from china is because they're putting
secret stuff in it to spy on us
yeah i mean yes okay all right but i
think like legally this commerce
department
entity list is only like can prevent u.s
companies from exporting things or
from selling technology to them right
yeah so but you're allowed to buy
whatever you want i guess
yeah so i think it's about time we uh we
ramped up this is my opinion maybe you
know you guys are the experts um
maybe we should sanction china to an
absolutely absurd degree across the
board until they end what they're doing
to the weaker muslims
well you'd need to get uh wall street on
board with that and that might be pretty
challenging
um i i got a shed full of pitchforks and
torches you got you got a couple
thousand people
maybe we can occupy wall street and uh
has that ever been tried before i don't
think so have careers ever been built on
that before
now interestingly i don't it actually it
was tried they never actually did they
never made it to wall street
they went to zuccotti park down the road
i was i was there the day they walked
into zupati park
it was weird yeah very weird but uh we
we have
what disney did mulan in you know where
they were
where they're where they have
concentration camps and then they
thank education camps right they're not
saying there's
concentration they're just they're just
trying to vocational training yeah
to lift them out of poverty is isn't
that weird and to prevent extremism
that's right yes yes
so disney famously thanked the uh what
was it called
the xinjiang public security bureau yeah
yeah a country that has public security
bureaus and ministry of security
yeah amazing and they kind of defended
themselves by going like well
we're just supposed to thank the you
know the areas that helped us
you know we filmed lots of places yeah
some had concentration camps
apparently some some of the people we
thanked were responsible for those
concentration camps you know
yeah it's not that we're thanking them
for the genocide no
no it's that we're just grateful that
some of these people won't be alive
anymore
well it's a family guy joke by the way
the official chinese communist stance is
that this is vocational training centers
that are a part of a poverty aviation
scheme to help train poor
rural workers to learn chinese and find
employment and they have to shave their
heads and make them wear jumpsuits right
it's just like it's almost it's almost
like a beautiful work of art the way
that they've managed to make all this
propaganda feed into each other because
one of the biggest propaganda elements
that they use in china is
we've lifted millions of people out of
poverty and they'll use that as like
a human rights thing like they'll be
like whenever like human rights day
rolls around like december 10th
uh they'll be like you know our biggest
human rights achievement is
lifting millions of people out of
property even though
they destroyed the economy uh in the
first place
and then when they backed off and
stopped you know controlling
everything and let people make money
again people lifted themselves out of
poverty
but the other part of it is they kind of
use that to cover up all their other
human rights atrocities
so if you talk about you know being out
of poverty as a human right that's
that's so so so just you know we kind of
made some
uh i guess we can call it the a dark
humor
crude joke very very dark but but i did
kind of rip off family guy in that one
from
in my defense but uh considering the
actual severity of the things that china
is doing particularly in this
particularly in this area
shouldn't we stop american companies
from investing in this kind of stuff or
from having factories from having
production
in china until they stopped doing this
yeah as i said earlier it's an issue of
like
people don't think of china as like a
horrible authoritarian regime that has
concentration camps
they think of it because china has been
very successful at a soft power push and
buying off
it's called elite capture uh basically
buying off politicians people in the
media
wall street like you said wall street uh
so it's just an issue of like
most americans don't know if like
americans really understood
what was happening i don't think they
would tolerate nike
trying to you know just shoot down a
forced labor bill
i mean they're doing it they are doing
that i don't think people really know
about that no
they don't and that's kind of scary you
know i've
had conversations with uh uh i had a
friend i have a friend from ukraine
and when i was there during the big you
know 2013-24 i think was 24
2013 when they had the the big protest
that ultimately led to separatist
movement and conflict
i was talking to a friend who was
talking about how she's going to make
the world a better place very lefty
leftist kind of mentality
and i said but do you really believe
that i mean the computer you're using
was made at the foxconn labs in
in china where people are walking off
the buildings in mass suicide because of
how horrific the conditions are
and she had no idea and it actually made
her cry when she
she was like i but i'm trying to help my
people i'm like yeah she's like i'm
trying to help the world be better and i
said no no no
you're trying to help yourself and your
community and i'm fine with that i can
respect that
you know you want the people in where
you live to do better but you realize
the fact that you have that computer and
that phone you have people
working in essentially slave labor
conditions jammed in these tiny boxes
and it's so bad they they actually put
up suicide nets around the building to
catch people from just walking off the
edge
i was like when you give them money
you're propping that system up and
you're actually making it worse
that kind of made her you know it's kind
of hard she kind of had a hard
realization of what was going
on you know well actually i think to an
extent if people were focused more on
building up their communities
uh you know the the issue is like the
when
china joined the world trade
organization like american manufacturing
got gutted
lots of jobs with to china you know it's
it's insane that
because of you know various regulations
it's cheaper to make stuff in china and
sail it all the way around the world
rather than having it made you're
telling me man
down the street boards really
skateboards the wood comes from canada
they ship it to china they make it into
a skateboard and ship it back to the us
now some of that's been changing a bit
now some of the manufacturing's done in
mexico but that was always the craziest
thing to me
they're like we make our boards from 100
pure rock canadian maple and i'm like
wow where's your factory in china
so you get the wood from canada send it
to china then send it back that's insane
and that is the cheaper option exactly
that's something
and it's because the people in china are
being paid
trash and there's no you know look if
you hire someone in north america
guess what you got to pay taxes you got
to pay health care and you already got
in in many circumstances
and the wages are typically much higher
so these big companies have found a way
to essentially extract what's what's
left of the value of the us and china
has found a way
because what essentially happens is the
american workers lose their jobs and
make no money then they eventually can't
even buy the product
so the rich people extract the money
from the poor people and then the people
getting paid are in china
and then eventually there's nothing left
for the people in this in this country
yep it's a it's a win-win for the super
rich that was
essentially a blueprint of what henry
kissinger richard nixon
and david rockefeller had proposed when
they went to china and quote opened up
china to the rest of the world and that
was such a significant
meeting and we still have to understand
the person who who
essentially blue planned this who made
this happen henry kissinger
he's still around being rewarded and
seen as some great kind of
diplomat meanwhile when we actually see
the ramifications of his actions
the consequences are severe and they
don't work out in anyone's favor
except for the super rich so i don't
know if you guys know a lot about the
opening of china but
i think you guys probably know more than
me about that
well gosh that's a huge did you see that
uh kissinger
was in the news a few weeks ago for
advising
biden to basically reset relations
with china wow yeah so the same guy who
made the blueprints is now telling biden
well trump trump fired him he uh he
purged the advisory board of the
pentagon which included kissinger i was
i was honestly shocked to hear that he
had a position that he could still be
fired from i don't know
the man he advises the pope okay
barack obama's national security adviser
says
that he no no there's a different one i
believe his name was o'neil
said that he takes his daily orders from
henry kissinger when he was the acting
national security advisor
so so kissinger has a lot of influence a
lot of powers but we see where his
allegiance
lies especially with the policies that
he set forward
that had these huge ramifications and
essentially destroyed
all the manufacturing blue-collar
middle-class jobs and they took them and
replaced them in china
where now we have all of our goods all
of our resources sent to them
to be processed by sometimes slaves
sometimes the uyghurs
sometimes by individuals who have no
other option but to make your little
goods and they send them back to you so
the super rich could sell you them on
amazon and walmart
walmart walmart who's investing in in
wuhan i don't know if people knew this
but walmart is investing a huge
substantial amount of their profits
to wuhan of all places in the world so
it's a safer investment think about it
in the united states we protect the
little guy to the best of our abilities
not perfect by any means the elites
certainly extract value
and can suppress and oppress you know uh
workers and unions and things like that
not that unions are perfect at all by
any stretch of the imagination
but with you know investment in china
you know that if your company is
successful
the chinese communist party will put the
boot down on anyone who dares oppose you
so you think about the risks in the
united states labor laws health care
why should we have to worry about the
little people
the elites in this country have found a
way to extract the value
partly by sending things be manufactured
for dirt wages in china
and then once they've gutted the
manufacturing base of this country
and everyone's settled with ridiculous
debt and the only way people can think
to get a job is to go to college rack up
massive debt and then they can't find a
job
that sounds familiar the elites will
just leave these are people with tons of
money
they've probably got money in panama or
wherever they were storing it cayman
islands or whatever
and they can easily just be like well
you know we've extracted all that we can
out of this country it's nothing left
but a withered husk
time to go to china invest in the in the
real estate or or the companies there
and then you have protections based on
the
authoritarianism of that nation they're
kind of screwing themselves though
really i don't have to say that because
they believe the chinese communist party
will not screw them and completely
like so many people have been screwed
going into china these businesses
tech companies um famously a few years
ago there was like a u.s
wind turbine manufacturer who made the
solar
not solar the wind turbines for wind
power and
they found out that their chinese joint
venture partner because legally you must
have a chinese company work with you
when you go into china you cannot
as well as party sells you have to have
if you have more than 50 employees in
china you must have a chinese communist
party branch
within your company this is law
and then they found out that their
partner was basically
replacing all of that they had stolen
their
property like intellectual property and
had replaced
their the stuff in their wind turbines
with their knockoff version
wow and they did amazing we're able to
take away all of their business and this
is not like an isolated incident it
happened to segway
yeah there was there was there was a
chinese knockoff segway
uh that stole their technology got so
much bigger
and then they bought segway wow and then
like nobody talks about it because you
don't want to admit
that this happened to you so then like
these companies go in they get screwed
uh then the pharma companies go in they
get screwed hollywood goes in
was it google supposed to go into china
weren't they making
they were in chinese chinese a chinese
google search engine which they scrapped
and aren't they still working on
artificial intelligence with the chinese
government what's the story with that
well so what happened with like uh back
in like 2000 was it seven eight
nine google was in china for a while uh
and they were trying to like kind of
work within the system you know censor
some stuff
but then like they hacked gmail and got
like
the uh information of a bunch of chinese
citizens and they were and then they
were at
to their credit at the time we're like
we're uncensoring
our search kick us out of china and then
a few years later
they realized that well they removed
don't be evil from their
line and uh then they started secretly
working on a sentence
search app that's a really weird thing
to do for anyone
even if you were planning on being evil
wouldn't you at least lie
but to be like we've once said we didn't
want to be evil but now we're kind of
thinking you know
go either way huh it wasn't interesting
i wonder who was behind that decision
they were like what happens if we have
to be evil
you know and then people are going to
yell at us let's just take it away and
then when we are evil we'll be like well
we got rid of that thing
that's why i don't blame them for what
they were doing i do think that google's
project dragonfly was one example of
something where
people made enough of a stink about it
that they could not
handle the bad pr and scrapped it yeah
even their employees were like what
because it was secret from the employees
right right right so
yeah that's a good example so the uh
pretty clearly like if the chinese
communist party like actually like sent
in
planes and troops and tanks and like
took over the united states you know
started gutting it
the manufacturing gutting like all the
technology in silicon valley
replaced politicians people would freak
out and it would be like the biggest
bloodiest insurgency in history but they
did it quietly
with money and influence so the same
things are happening
they bought off a lot of people in in
hollywood in the media
and the same things are happening
intellectual property theft
silicon valley uh so we have been
invaded just
what they call unrestricted warfare i'd
put it this way if
china invaded the us started seizing
large swaths of land
started compromising our politicians and
sleeping with certain california
congressmen
and stripping away intellectual property
rights and
basically you know using our own
companies against us
censoring our movies then then what
would happen is the american people i
tell you this because the american
people
are lazy and complacent they'd roll over
and be like well you know i'm not to do
anything about it
we literally have joe biden they say is
going to be the president on january
20th he's going to be inaugurated
and we've already had one of his former
family confidants tony babilinski come
out and say
i believe joe biden is compromised by
china
we have two investigations into the
biden family from jim biden joe's
brother
and hunter biden and we know for a fact
that joe biden himself
flew his son on air force two to china
for these private equity deals
my first question is i don't care what
you got to say about any of these
investigations
shouldn't we stop and be like why is joe
biden using government property to
enrich his son
why why did he bring his son on this
plane to negotiate this deal
that's suspect already father-son
bonding yeah
or outright and overt corruption by
which 80 million people will support
it so i tell you if the chinese were
like we're going to take over your
country you'd have 80 million people
screaming and clapping and cheering for
it
well they don't how were they supposed
to know about the hunter buying thing
the media like that
actively censored that social media we
got smeared for covering that actually
we did yeah that it was like that it was
far-right
russian disinformation yeah that's right
despite the criminal investigation that
is actually going on and
i mean we knew about it yeah and despite
the email that happened in 2017 with
hunter biden asking a very chine a very
famous chinese energy tycoon
best wishes for the holidays and asking
him for 10 million dollars
or or where he said um we're trying to
get a room for
you know we're trying to get an office
for for everybody
including this you know chinese company
as well as joe and whatever they were
office mates i suppose
so look the the the there's enough i
would say circumstantial evidence
to in my opinion warrant riots in the
streets
from the american people and they said
you had pitchforks here
yeah i have a squeegee that's as close
as i can get to something on a stick to
so the pitchfork was a lie yes it was
fake news i
i am disillusioned by this show i do
have matches though
the the really good ones they're the
strike anywhere matches
so you can hold it up and you'll look
not nearly as angry
yeah you'll burn your fingers in like 20
seconds
i think you can't use that analogy
anymore about like uh torches and
pitchforks ever since
ever since the tiki torches became like
the wrong kind of thing you know what i
mean oh yeah
but uh but so so uh you know i'm looking
at a lot about what's going i'm looking
a lot what's going on say in in new york
and california
it's not just that our economy is being
gutted our manufacturing is being sent
over to china
we don't even make our own medicine
anymore that was the craziest thing when
we we had a pandemic
pandemic it and we're like we need
medicine quick call china
because we don't have any factories that
can actually make it the coronavirus
really
made a lot of people become aware of of
the situation
like when like medical supplies even
things like kettlebells you couldn't get
it because everything was made in china
i mean right now it's really hard it's
still hard to get a lot of
specific equipment professional
equipment
bicycles it's all made in china it's
interesting on the medical side like
we actually do do a lot of
pharmaceuticals but a lot of the raw
ingredients
so the things that go into the drugs
come from china
and there's nowhere else that you can
get them and the craziest thing too is
uh
rare earth minerals right which we use
for i guess smartphones among other
things
we get them from we get it all almost
exclusively from china right
japan does did recently find like a big
surprise but it's everywhere
it's actually not uncommon to find there
are rare earth minerals in the u.s
yeah yeah but we just go for it china
we're just going to give all of our
money and keep printing it
now we've got 35 percent of all us
dollars just being printed like crazy
we've got to wait to get some we've got
new york california michigan these
states
have violated the constitution beyond
any record like i mean listen
if you come out you say we have an
argument about gun control i understand
the second amendment but you can still
have a right to keep and bear arms with
some restrictions there's an argument
and people actually argue it
although many people are now becoming
rather too absolutist because of you
know the riots and the craziness
but in in uh you look at new york
andrew cuomo was like if you're
protesting
you're okay you have your rights if
you are pro joe biden please come out
dance in the street and drink champagne
together
but if you want to go to a church never
going to happen
if you want to run your business because
you're running out of money and you need
to feed your family
no dice this is extreme degrees
of authoritarian despotic
i don't even know is there a word more
harsh than i can get
psychopathic malevolence where he's
basically sent
you know he had nypd going to jewish
schools with children
and the cops would point their phones
inside the windows to film them
to prosecute nypd police officers went
undercover to a restaurant ordered food
and then as soon as the person delivered
it arrested them that's the level of uh
depravity coming from the likes of cuomo
and no one
no one in this country is doing anything
in that the police officers support it
so you know to wrap to make sure i'm not
trying to get off on a tangent outside
of the china stuff
when we hear that there is chinese
authoritarian communism and things like
this
the american people seem to just roll
over and take it for the most part in
these blue cities
but but i'll tell you i don't see the
political willpower from trump
supporters or anyone who could do
anything to stop it at this point
they're going to completely destroy the
economy and they already have
the federal debt to gdp ratio is now at
128.6 percent
we're we're we're dropping and
collapsing so quickly that when many
people talk about thucydides trap and i
talk
are you familiar with this at district i
talked about it quite a bit several
months ago
that there's been fear for years that we
will eventually get into a full-scale
war a hot war with china because there
are rising economic power
well i guess there's one way to avoid it
have our own politicians destroy this
country from the inside out and then
there won't need to be a war
you know i think uh we did this we did
this episode
pretty early on the coronavirus called
the cure for coronavirus is not
authoritarian
authoritarianism and it was based on the
idea that like
the chinese communist party was trying
to use their model of controlling the
coronavirus which is
like locking people in their homes like
literally welding them into them welding
people in their homes
dragging people out of their homes to
put them in quarantine you know
arresting people like beating people up
for being on the streets when there was
a lockdown
um and kind of like providing that as a
model
for other countries as to like this is
the way to deal with it and you did
something
a virus western media somewhere like hey
you know it's mind it might be a little
authoritarian but it's working
yeah like you know they they got rid of
it so it kind of works so i think
in a way like the things that you're
talking about in new york or
the excess of things that they're doing
in california and these different places
like
you know it was almost like it was like
it happened in china that they did this
lockdown then it happened in italy that
they did the lockdown it kind of gave
permission in a way for all of these
you know people politicians in different
areas to be like this is the way to deal
with it and because
of it yeah and because china lies about
uh the actual coronal virus numbers it
seems effective
but the numbers in china are completely
fake it's it's obvious if you look at it
yeah i really wanted to ask you this but
it's kind of strange
that these kind of top democrats even
the new york city mayor today bill de
blasio came out and just
plainly said i'd like to say very
bluntly our mission is to redistribute
wealth
so it's very interesting seeing these
democrats kind of mimic
the language and some of the behaviors
of the communist chinese but
from your sources from from the people
you talk to on the ground what's really
going on there
did they defeat the coronavirus because
we're seeing a lot of photos of them
raving and partying and having these
huge
the marathon the street marathon yes how
does like how does
how do you guys make sense of this story
of this deadly pandemic
everywhere but china's having street
parties and raves
at the same time did their lockdowns uh
work like what what's going on here well
first of all i know you have some
specific things you want to say about
that shelly but
um like over the past couple of months
you keep seeing like certain cities in
china declaring
uh wartime measures to fight the
coronavirus because there's
oh some rumor that maybe like somebody
got a case and then suddenly they need
to
test 70 000 people in a city and they
can do that in like three days because
it's a
horrible authoritarian regime but so you
get the sense that uh
it never did stop there is still
something happening
uh the extent of which we can't know and
i know you have some specific things you
were talking about earlier
oh yeah just the idea that you know well
i mean in terms of the numbers there's
no way to
like you cannot there's no way to even
guess because it's not really going to
be based in reality because
like their gdp numbers the gdp numbers
aren't real um
you know there was you know china's been
organ
force organ harvesting from dissidents
and
you know it turns out that like some
people did a study and found out that
like
the whole since 2015 they've claimed
that they only have organs coming from
you know voluntary donations you know
sure sure i get a couple kidneys i don't
need yeah and then they
basically these researchers found out
that their voluntary donation numbers
and their transplant numbers were all
fake they all
mimicked a quadratic equation
almost perfectly so are they are they
actually harvesting organs
they are from political prisoners they
are doing
uyghurs they're definitely doing organ
transplants
their official numbers are fake yeah yes
yeah surprise surprise isn't their real
estate all fake too
uh yeah uh this is yeah
you know i watched uh i was watching a
video someone posted on facebook i
remember what it was but maybe you guys
know
where a guy was explaining the the
warfare strategy of china
is exploiting the weaknesses of a nation
that they accept so
if you allow free speech then we'll
support protests against you
if racism is a very sensitive issue then
we'll inflame it and we'll just keep
pushing it and pushing and pushing it
and that what we're seeing right now is
actually the fifth generational war
full scale with china they know that if
they actually
you know crashed some u-boats on the
shores of california and ran in full
speed
they might have a very large ground army
but the people would fight back and the
americans would win
air superiority for for one thing plus
all the aircraft carriers we got
so what they're doing is subversion
manipulating our systems
stock market buying land control you
know they're they're coming in they're
undermining all of our institutions
it's working and it's and it's being
it's collapsing underneath us
and i wonder when we hear things like
that from bill de blasio
these people like build i look at the
chinese communist party i think they're
very smart
very very very smart they understand why
they had to have some kind of
capitalistic system
in their country to actually allow it to
expand economically
because you know the things they were
doing very early on kind of didn't work
like didn't they kill all these birds at
one point or something
[Music]
right that was like didn't do anything
did it like they had kids literally
pulling
grass out of the ground because grass
was bourgeoisie
so like clearly that stuff didn't work
but now you have people like bill de
blasio who clearly is not a smart person
saying we're gonna do this you know
reader should be wealth so it seems like
they've bought and paid for as many
elites as they can you've got the
thousand talents project
program or whatever out of these
universities where these people are
essentially spies
it's really amazing they're not getting
charged with treason and then the way
they've
gotten a hold of universities is is
horrifying
and is it is it what is it is it a
coincidence then that the universities
are
the epicenter for the most part of this
woke
broken theory critical critical theory
that makes them hurt about what you're
talking about and have no knowledge
none what's up no no
so no no no never never never we're
playing it safe right shelly
super safe apparently well i think that
in a way like the chinese communist
party is happy to see us destroy
ourselves
but um they don't really care if we
follow communism as an ideology that's
not really what they care about what
they care about is
having the us become weakened and so
they can
continue to you know um
oppress all these other countries and
like you know specifically their growing
influence in
asia pacific yeah definitely so so uh
the reason i bring this up is we had a
story in the new york times
uh it was it was updated a couple days
ago but it was from about a week or so
ago
where a university professor said we
should not give the vaccine to the
elderly
because they tend to be more white and
we need to level the playing field with
minorities
which is one of the craziest things i've
ever seen written in the new york times
where they outright said this professor
believes older white people should die
to balance the number of harvard
professor uh no no university of
pennsylvania oh okay
oh but at the same time almost at the
same time at the same time
from the college fix we have a story
about cornell which is mandating
only the white students get the vaccine
so the critical race theory stuff
is completely nonsensical
it just makes literally no sense to be
like well it's racist
to give the vaccine to the you know to
the white people so we're going to give
to the minorities but the same time
only the white people should be forced
to get it it's like that theory makes no
like none of that makes sense right this
ideology clearly has
no no end point no goal
no success it's just chaos and so when
you see this coming out of universities
you see things like this the thousand
talents program i'm not i don't want to
get
too conspiratorial but i think when
you're talking about china trying to
subvert this country and they have a
program in which they buy
out university professors and then you
have many university professors who are
espousing nonsensical ideas that will
only destroy this country
i kind of feel like there's some lines
to be connected there maybe i'm wrong
the thousand talents is mostly about
science and tech stuff
because what they really want to do with
that is steal us technology and bring it
to china
literally paying professors to bring
their research
not not to say that specifically they're
using thousand talents to espouse this
kind of
weird you know far left or critical race
theory stuff just that i think
if they're willing to do that in
universities would they not be willing
to
push this other kind of ideology because
it eats us alive from the inside
i do think that the the critical race
theory is interesting in the sense that
the chinese communist party is like what
you said about the video where they'll
use
our weaknesses against us or our they'll
use our strengths against us
and make them weaknesses so with the
racism thing that's
one of the things that they've
definitely been using especially in
australia
well in australia but also here to when
people started blaming china for the
coronavirus that was definitely racist
it's racist to talk about it asians
asians are white
yeah that's the new thing right yeah
yeah i was very happy to tell chelsea
yeah i was very disappointed to learn i
was actually i was really excited
because it turns out that i'm double
white
because you know yeah yeah right so i
get to be white twice so is that like
is that more power you have i don't know
does this mean super privilege you are
or aren't going to get the vaccine
uh well for my allergies i'm not oh um
oh i actually do have allergies yeah
yeah not legitimate
back to our topic i think i think i
think you guys were hey quiet down we're
talking about something interesting
allergies tell me more yes i think you
guys were talking about the larger
divide and conquer agenda and it is
interesting to see a lot of special
interests from china
do give a lot of money to the
universities and it is kind of
exemplified as we saw with again i'm
going to bring this back to mayor bill
de blasio because his administration
during the early onset of the
coronavirus was saying
it's fine don't be racist come out to
the chinese day parade everything's
going to be fine
don't worry racist and then next week
he's literally threatening martial law
where even andrew como had to stop
bill de blasio and said wait hold on
there you're pushing it too far
if you're going farther than andrew coma
wants you to go
you know you're a lunatic and you
absolutely lost it and he has been a
part of this larger divide and conquer
supporting black lives matter protests
openly
calling for demonstrations meanwhile
telling you you can't have dinner with
your family because it's going to spread
the coronavirus and kill everyone
and and this black lives matter thing
also we have to admit here
is being exploited by the chinese as
there have been many chinese diplomats
that have come out and said the united
states is racist
you know look at we we support black
lives matter there was even a police
officer in in hong kong
that was screaming at american
journalists there black lives matter
as he was beating the crap out of the
dissidents
in hong kong so we have to understand
there is an element of this exploitation
of our racial divide
by the chinese whether it's being
weaponized or just exploited i think
is is something a topic of debate that i
think we should talk about
i think the it's their favorite thing to
bring up in
racism because it's like that's the
number one thing that they can like
anything they can hit us with i know it
hits a nerve yeah and it's it hits a
nerve in the us
and also like it's everything they do is
what about ism in a certain sense where
like if you try to bring up
human rights atrocities in china the
first thing they'll do is
bring the racism or whatever steve kerr
did this
remember the nba guy he was like i don't
go around asking about our police
brutality problems you know and we got
we got issues we got to deal with it's
like bro
you don't talk about police brutality we
can you want to talk about concentration
camps we have to
did that happen with uh was it mark
cuban somebody who oh yeah who was like
that was also terrible because he was
like china is a customer
but we should treat each other but we
should you know
we should start in our own like clean up
our own house yeah
that's the fundamental problem you need
they talk about china like it's our
customer instead of oh
the chinese communist party has
concentration camps and harvests the
organs of people who have
wrong political beliefs i think that's
one thing like joe biden came out with a
with a statement during human rights
international human rights day which was
the 10th
and what was disappointing was that he
kind of focus
he was like yes there are many human
rights atrocities around the world
but then was like we have to talk about
systemic injustices
here in america and whatever and that's
fair but
it's kind of like it is it is very
similar to chinese propaganda
in the sense that they're always talking
about like well before you can talk
about
what's wrong in other countries you have
to clean if you're not perfect
you cannot talk about anything else
jordan peterson says clean your room
bucko
you know you you can't you see jordan
peterson's communist yeah that's what
i'm getting here
i'm saying he's secretly subverting
american
yeah i mean you can't compare the two
it's not apples and oranges when you
compare black lives matter to the
uyghurs
especially when you look at the kind of
xenophobia and the treatment of
blacks in china and there was amazing
incredible video that that came out that
was off stunning
showing what was happening with the
chinese government literally blaming
black people for the coronavirus
inside of china kicking them out of
their own
homes kicking them out into the street
and then and then this is the country
lecturing us about black lives matter
they made a commercial
where there's a black man put into a
washing machine
and you guys i'm sure you saw this and
it was it was it created an outro
on uproar in the u.s because so for
those haven't seen the commercial
there's a chinese woman and a black man
she pushes the black man in the washing
machine and he comes out chinese
and there was there was outrage in the
u.s and china's china's response was
they're like are you americans you bite
soi you you crazies
you're so sensitive grow up they didn't
care there was nothing they never do
black face yeah the cctv you can go
ahead
yeah but every year they have this uh
communist uh gala
new year's show and yeah last i think
was last year they had uh
like somebody dressing up about like
africa yeah like
china and africa and how they're like
helping all the african people and they
had like an actress in blackface
and as like ever like so many of the uh
you know
experts from africa we've talked to are
saying like this is colonialism it's a
neo-colonialism
so i remember spending time in africa
doing reporting and i was surprised how
many chinese nationals were
at the airport at the hotels and they're
building a chinese surveillance
station yes most importantly i mean i
was in kenya and zimbabwe and somalia
and even in somalia i saw some chinese
nationals which was pretty
surprising to say the least but talking
to almost
every african a lot of them brought up
to me the chinese are here
they're taking over they are the new
colonizers this is crazy
what's happening here and i was shocked
to the level of how many africans were
talking to me about this seriously
whether it was taxi drivers whether it
was waiters whether it was random people
that i walked
into or was interviewing they're like
you should really take it take a look
into china
and how they're essentially taking over
all of africa
and usurping all of our natural
resources and buying off our politicians
and it was surprising because i didn't
know about it until i was in africa and
actually saw it on the ground there well
this actually goes to a point tim was
making earlier about how
the chinese communist party is a threat
to democracy worldwide so there's the
influence that's
the communist party is having in like
the united states and australia but on
on like using africa as an example what
they'll do is they'll go to
dictators horrible regimes and say hey
uh we'll give you
money that the west isn't giving you and
we won't tie you know freedom of the
press or any of those things
to it we'll also give you huawei
technology to help you
spy on and track down opposition leaders
so we will make you a more effective
authoritarian leader
and so this is how like every year like
a freedom house uh
organization uh rates like at the
progress of freedom and democracy in the
world and like we've seen a backslide
because of the influence of the chinese
communist party it's this there's these
two competing
spheres of power and unfortunately the
authoritarian commerce model of china is
is rapidly growing and if they ever take
over taiwan
yeah that will be a disaster i think do
you i think that'll happen under joe
biden do you think so
uh well so then we should be talking
about like uh
kirk campbell and jake sullivan like
people who might be um
working for the uh abide in
administration some things they've said
and it does seem
what are some examples and who are these
people okay so uh jake sullivan was
the national security adviser to vice
president biden
biden wants him as the national security
adviser
and he talked about how um like he
considers
china's rise like one of his great
successes he was working for that
and he and kirk sullivan kirk campbell
uh penned an editorial in foreign
affairs where they
they talk about um well like
keeping the status quo with taiwan for
instance
and china has promised to invade taiwan
yeah
are they they're doing beaching drills
yeah and they uh normally like
every year there's like this message
about peaceful reunification they were
moved peaceful
so you know what happens when the status
quo is changed by the chinese communist
party invading taiwan what are the what
are they going to say about that
kirk campbell yeah kirk campbell was
also behind one of the biggest foreign
policy failures of the u.s since like
the fall of saigon with the
scarborough shoal incident in 2002 2012.
what was that
so the scarborough shoal we actually
went there
we'll see we can tell that story later
um it's like this
uh this reef kind of near the
philippines it's very important to local
filipino fishermen
it's in the south china sea and
originally it was kind of a place where
filipino fishermen and vietnamese
fishermen chinese fishermen they could
all go and fish in the place
it was claimed by several different
countries including the philippines and
china
yeah but then in 2012 china sends in its
uh
coast guard and basically occupies the
shoal
um kirk campbell leads the u.s
delegation to because
the philippines are a treaty ally with
the u.s
uh we have a mutual defense pack with
them so this might
trigger that right that they came in
they come to blow it looked like they
were going to come to blows
whoa and so they they they work out this
deal where you know the chinese will
leave and the philippine side will leave
and that'll be fine
well the philippine forces leave the
chinese forces stay
yeah and the us did nothing
under trump no this was under this 2012
under obama oh that's right wow and this
sent
shock waves throughout the asia pacific
because suddenly this was like
all of these other countries realizing
if the us will turn its back
on a mutual defense ally what's gonna
happen to us we
so thailand began moving closer to the
chinese communist party
philippines south korea we also lost
south korea
when um we were putting in the thaad
missile defense system
and china freaked out about that and
began a huge economic warfare against
south korea
no support from the u.s i was uh uh we
were both the luke and i were in south
korea and there were people protesting
the
the thaad defense system yeah i mean it
was controversial within south korea
that is true
that is definitely true but so this was
like devastating for the image of the
u.s
uh all throughout the year that was
obama that was under obama and
specifically this
agreement was negotiated by for a guy
who loved war
you think he'd have done something i
mean supposedly
i mean supposedly somebody said we're
not going to go to war over a bunch of
rocks
i was that kirk it might have been i
think it was that's insane
so but like the wider geopolitical
effect it has disastrous for the us it
was terrible and it allowed china to
basically have free reign within the
south china sea in general i don't think
they were prepared for that i think that
totally rewrote
their their their timeline of what they
could do things because after that
that's when you see them really
building up artificial islands and
militarizing these tolls right they've
like these these are yes and stuff
because now they have like missiles on
them yeah and
when the us says hey don't build those
missiles what do you think
china is going to do well when uh do you
do you remember recently when they did
the elephant
march i think it's called in guam
elephant march yeah so
uh when the strike group from china went
through the
that straight between taiwan and what's
it called the taiwan street taiwan
straight i guess uh
trump had deployed bombers and and heavy
military forces to an air base in guam
and then they did i guess what's called
an elephant walk or something
where you see all of these war you know
planes going you know around
showing them look what we got ready to
go and then we were treated
because the us military found out that
china has weapons capable of wiping out
the entire air base before those planes
can get off the ground
so we were forced to pull back and
retreat well that also reminds me of
that the chinese navy has more ships
than the u.s now
which are not necessarily the same
equivalent in terms of
technical capability yeah but the u.s
military has been so focused on
the sandbox yeah and not on
china i'll tell you not that it's a
one-for-one comparison
or a comparison at all but i think most
people who play strategy games know
the power of a wave of
small troops versus one powerful unit
so we often hear from the from the the
u.s uh gun control advocates when they
say
what you think you're going to go to war
against the american government they
have
cruise missiles and the typical response
is
if you think uh if if that's what you
think you need to look up the history of
vietnam and afghanistan
a handful of people with weapons is is
going to outdo you know it's going to
easily i'll put it this way
fighter jets can't occupy street corners
so there is something to be said for
china having more ships
even if they're not nearly as capable
because uh you know
and and correct me if i'm wrong i mean i
don't think you guys are experts on you
know world war ii in russia but i was
reading about how
russia mass-produced really low quality
tanks
that were getting blown up like crazy by
the nazis but they just had so many
just can't wave after wave of our own
men that's kind of the ak strategy right
the what strategy the the ak-47 just
like achieve ease like
yup simple gun versus like the m what
was the m6 they like bro
had all kinds of issues the academy you
could bury in the mud and still use it
make something that is cheap but easy to
produce
and fast and then sure the nazis were
able to blow up these russian tanks but
they just kept sending wave after wave
because they could just keep making them
well that's
brannigan's strategy exactly wave after
wave of our own men
until we run out of bullets we have to
understand when we look at china's
strategy now it's it's
pretty pretty brilliant i mean
historically china hasn't been that
strong because of its geopolitical
location
but if they're able to offset the fight
on islands
especially along very important trade
routes they're implementing a similar
policy like the japanese did during
world war ii they don't want the fight
in tokyo they want the fight in the
pacific
so this is the first beginning of this
chinese expansion which they need
because essentially they're landlocked
and they're landlocked in not
a strong position when you look at their
natural resources they're not
doing that well as you said they just
imported a whole bunch of grain
because it's very hard for the chinese
government and the chinese
country to produce for itself this is
why they're also trying to expand their
territory
in the himalayas against the troops in
india so
we're seeing if china really wants to
dominate the world they're going to have
to have a bunch of islands
along these trade routes and if you look
at world wars
they always start along trade routes so
this is very key and and one of the
reasons why they're building so many of
these uh strategic locations that
they're expanding it so we have to
keep watching that yeah five trillion
dollars of shipping goes through the
south china sea yes yes
and so they need that seaport control
yes that's why it's so important to them
and the reason why they're putting the
uyghur muslims in these camps is because
they need total social control
people who adhere to a religion have a
higher power
they need to be the power weren't they
replacing image like religious images
with like chairman mao
yeah definitely i mean that's been going
on for a while yeah well also
now it's the same strategy they've
actually been using
all throughout uh the 70 years of the
chinese communist party history like
everything that's happening
in xinjiang now uh to a lesser extent
they did to the falun gong practitioners
before that
and we were just talking to somebody
from southern mongolia
uh which is an inner monk which is in
here mongolia they did the same wave of
genocide in mongolia that
people don't really hear about they did
it in tibet these these are all the same
things just the same strategies just
being refined and refined
and we just don't stop i'll tell you
something crazy uh
there was a period where just i'll just
say some someone that i know
very well would make you was a youtuber
and they got an email one day from
someone who asked them to
upload a video to their youtube channel
not to run an ad not to do a promo to
straight hey would you be
would you be willing to upload a video
to your channel in exchange for 200
the video was some guy in new york
talking about falun gong
and how backwards it was but it was a
really interesting bit of propaganda
where the person wasn't saying falun
gong is bad they were like
it's so strange that we we allow this
weird
cult-like religion in our country why
would we do this
you know we have these people and
they're dangerous and it's like a
really really i said i said don't upload
that don't take the money
but people did so so they found channels
that were small to mid-size maybe 10
20 000 subscribers or more would just be
like wow a couple hundred bucks i need
the money and they would upload this
propaganda piece from china
wow yeah it's it's amazing like all the
little pieces of propaganda that
are able to filter into the yeah can you
guys explain some of the larger
propaganda efforts that are utilized in
china i know there's a crackdown on
religions
but i also have seen videos of people
rebelling and fighting against the the
chinese government as well
is there anything legitimately going on
or is the propaganda so strong with the
social credit score that there isn't any
resistance at all
oh okay um here's here's an interesting
story that kind of ties
ties into that um it might seem
tangential
uh there was a story uh this past year
of uh
a chinese student who was studying in
the u.s he did a he made a post
to twitter in the u.s comparing
chinese chairman xi jinping to the
villain
from biker mice from mars
okay and then he goes back to china and
is arrested for that
so the the first and biggest victims of
the chinese communist party's actions
are always
the chinese people themselves yeah um
now i think you should tell the story
about uh chengwan chen what he told you
oh yeah we um chugwan chen is a blind
chinese human rights act he's the
daredevil he's the uh he was a
he was a barefoot lawyer in china and he
was
arrested for basically trying to help
women who had had forced abortions
uh because of the one child policy and
he was just trying to help them
get some kind of like legal redress
china is anti-choice and anti-life
yeah yeah just both and then uh
he was put in prison for years for you
know traffic violations
um wow and then he was put into house
arrest for many years too but he managed
to
escape house arrest uh and
uh make his way to beijing we had
activists helping him and he made made
it to the u.s embassy
wow uh back in 2012 and the us ended up
granting him asylum oh wow um so we
interviewed him last year
and he was talking about how you know
it looks from the surface to a lot of
people like
the chinese people as a whole support
the chinese communist party especially
because a lot of the chinese
nationals that you'll meet in places
like the us they're rich
and they're rich because their families
have some connection to the party
or their families are party members like
they have
some kind of wealth that's tied back to
the communist party so
you know and also all the young people
have been kind of brainwashed
uh to be very nationalistic so they'll
be very supportive of the chinese
communist party but that's not the
real case on the ground but you can't
know that because even on the internet
chinese people are very careful about
what they say because they know
that you're going to get sent to prison
for you know saying the wrong thing on
wechat or whatever
so they won't say it online they're
they're they're videos i've seen where
you know somebody might be filming in
china and then they ask a question the
person will like go under their breath
and be like i don't know i can't talk
about this yeah and so yeah that's so he
was saying that
there are people there are so many
people who are against the chinese
communist party
but it is hard unless you have the
connections inside china to know that
they're there
i want to point something out real quick
too uh because there's a stereotype
about chinese people being really bad
drivers
right you've probably heard it the
family guy is a joke where
you know just the other day we're
watching family guy there's a chinese
woman and she's like how many
how long do i need a signal to change
eight lanes and then she just crashes
the car whatever
but uh i was talking to uh this guy you
know who who spent a lot of time
a lot a lot of his life in china and he
said what people don't realize
the chinese who can make it to the
united states tend to be wealthier than
those who are
who stay in china it's only possible and
many of these people have their own
drivers
their whole lives in china they come
here and they they're not drivers
they're the wealthier people so now they
have to drive themselves
and so it's a class issue of where you
end up seeing these stereotypically bad
drivers
not to say that it's legitimately true
that you know every person is bad at
driving but he pointed out
you don't realize these are the wealthy
people who are coming here
and that's why the stereotype you know
ends up coming about
i mean in china people are notoriously
bad drivers but that's also because
they've only been driving since like the
early 2000s really
oh wow it wasn't long ago yeah bicycles
yeah so
most people had not been driving that
long so
there's a lot of like you know the kind
of traffic adequate that
like the kind of stuff that's not
necessarily a law but like people learn
like you know you're going to let people
into the lane if they need to like merge
or whatever that stuff doesn't exist
right like that kind of culture because
they haven't been driving though it's
pretty easy to just find like horrific
videos of like like someone crossing the
street and then just
like at 100 miles an hour boom run over
by
there's a lot of videos there's a huge
emerging middle class in china which is
looking like it's going to be a problem
for the larger government
it's very interesting to see how they're
going to address that problem but very
interestingly when you talked about the
one child policy i automatically thought
about many american elites
uh a lot of specialized high-level
individuals like ted turner that are
fans
of the one child policy and have
complimented it
uh before on the american stage as well
so there it is interesting to see
the kind of ties to a lot of these
individuals i actually talked to ted
turner and i asked him
if you believe in the one child policy
as you as much as you do and
as much as you advocate for it why do
you have four children
he didn't like that question but well
it's it rules for thee but not for me
of course yeah yeah that's how it is i
mean some animals are more
equal even the one child policy
the is the one child policy was a
failure
absolutely absolutely and the chinese
government kind of
knows it but they can't say it because
they can't admit they made them
yeah so they that's why there's now a
two-child policy instead of a one-child
policy because they realize they screwed
themselves with the
population control and just a big
picture for a moment the chinese
communist party has concentration camps
harvest organs and for many years it was
illegal to have a brother or a sister
wow well
there were some there were some like
this rule is it like
the thing with chinese law or policy is
that like it's a very
unevenly actually it's kind of like they
have like a decree from up top and then
like it's up to the local
officials to implement it and they do it
very unevenly depending on where you are
so if you're in like a wealthier area
maybe you just have to pay a fine and
you can afford it
to have another kid uh in the rural
areas like
that's like the more disadvantaged you
are like the more likely that it's going
to be like you get hauled into a van
or a forced abortion or something like
that because they have to make an
example out of you
and also the terrible thing was that a
lot of these family planning
policies like the one child policy they
were a way for local governments to make
money so if they couldn't find you then
they would make an example out of you
and uh that even like you know in the
90s a lot of people were starting to
adopt chinese girls like
right in the u.s and other because they
were like oh well girls aren't wanted
so you know there's 30 million more men
right so
that's what i wanted to ask right did
they create this imbalance where there's
not enough women for the men know
they did but also there was like
something
that weird that happened where there
became a black market
for chinese baby girls to sell
to be adopted in the u.s why
because like they would like let's say
you had a second child
and it was a girl and you didn't want to
give the kid up they could take the kid
from you and put in an orphanage
and the local government could be like
this baby was abandoned
and then so you had cases of like
families where like their kid was
literally taken from them
and then you know the adoptive parents
like usually pay
hundreds or maybe a couple of thousand
dollars to the local government for the
adoption
so the local government is making money
off of like stealing kids
and selling them to be adopted to the
u.s yeah
and sex trafficking is such a huge issue
like i know the trump administration uh
uh sanctioned or not sanctioned but like
uh called out china for human
trafficking
but yeah that's that's a big way they're
dealing with this gender imbalance uh
yes uh sex trappings came from
north korea you know from like yeah
our our show it's got lots of funny
humor it's
it's fun to watch do you think a hot war
is
inevitable or possible in our lifetimes
i
i
it depends on a lot of factors um
i think would be more of a slow
the worst case scenario i think would be
a slow
choking death for the u.s uh the u.s
doesn't do anything
but it's not over yet at this point i
don't i don't know if i agree
it's if if they ever invade taiwan
that will be the the moment if the u.s
lets that happen
that's that's probably horrible i think
joe biden will
i think you've already outlined the
people he's surrounding himself with and
i didn't even know about that was it
the scarborough shoal yeah that's that's
that's horrifying biggest foreign policy
failure since like the fall of saigon
and like hardly anyone knows about it
and they and they scream you know uh
trump is the worst and obama had no
scandals
and that's shocking because look he wore
a tan suit that's that's true
see i think you know uh one of the
things that luke and i talk about a lot
especially i think most people when it
comes to the obama administration and
foreign policy is clearly the middle
east libya syria for
really good examples the drone strikes
in yemen things like that
i didn't even know about that that he
essentially abandoned our allies in this
in the south in the south
in southeast asia i think they started
to realize towards the end of this
obama's second term that they had kind
of screwed up in asia there was the
pivot to asia
but it was kind of it ended up being
more of a pr kind of thing than actually
policy i i look i think you know we had
the tpp it didn't include china but
you know these these free trade
agreements that uh the obama
administration was very much in favor of
the things joe biden has advocated for
when i hear tony babilinski you know
he's a guy he's
he's the guy who basically blew the
whistle in the biden family say they're
compromised when i hear
look there's a lot of things we can call
under a biden for these equity deals the
five the five million dollar forgivable
interest-free loan
but joe biden that was a nice deal that
was a great deal it's great
they say you know joe biden wasn't
involved in any capacity but
i got to bring it up again you know he
actually
flew with government property air force
two his son to china for these private
equity
it didn't go through you know but that's
part of the connection it did go through
it did go through it it did go through
the thing about that private equity deal
is like
the hunter bind lawyer came up with a
denial but if you read the denial it's
actually very cleverly worded
because a lot of people don't know how
private equity deals work i didn't when
i was reading
about this hunter biden scandal at first
when it first came out a couple years
ago so
i thought oh well like the what the
lawyer said is correct like he only put
half a million dollars in or whatever
and but like the truth is that that
money like the private equity deal
actually did go through
and it's involved in a really weird way
with chinese state-owned corporations
where
it seems like why would these
state-owned corporations
need this private equity firm made out
of just
americans so to come in because like
they're
the state-owned corporations are
essentially the banks are lending money
to the state-owned corporations
there's no reason for like a western
private equity firm to come into this
so we we heard that uh that viral video
di dong shang i think is pronounced
and he said you know now that biden is
in
you know trump talked a lot about his
son hunter and how he built up this
wealth and then he says who do you think
got him that
and the audience laughs and he says got
it yeah when you see things like that
okay with the air force two scenario the
private equity deal
i tell you man uh i believe tony bobby
that that
joe biden's compromised and this creates
a very very nightmarish scenario for
americans when we're watching
specific states you know i'll single out
the democrats on this one that are
essentially using the constitution as
toilet paper and then you have the real
threat that
china is it looks like they're preparing
a ground invasion of taiwan
is that fair to say is that is that too
bold they're definitely preparing ground
invasion of taiwan yeah
it's hard to know how close they are to
actually being able to pull that off
um it's difficult but it could only
happen at like two different times of
the year
it's a very narrow weather right joe
biden's not going to defend him
well so i think the at an absolute
minimum with the hunter biden stuff at
an absolute minimum he had like
he had a points secret service watching
over him
it's impossible that biden did not have
joe biden did not know something was
happening yeah
uh it just it's too much of a stretch of
the imagination
look if if if you guys are even
somewhat jokingly but it seems very
serious to say that chinese
authoritarian communists or chinese
countries authoritarians are invading
this country they're subverting it
and you've got these people coming in
the biden administration who you say
are proud of what's going on you know uh
luke mentioning henry kissinger advising
obama's national security adviser is
that who it was
then at what point do the american
people have to rise up in the streets
and do something about it
when you buy those pitchforks so you're
saying if i if i buy them right now
if you buy it they won't come yes
if you buy it they will also what what
time of year would the
chinese invade march
yeah otherwise the weather it's just
impossible yeah as soon as joe biden won
i i i the first thing i said this is not
a loss for just donald trump this is a
loss for taiwan
which essentially is being isolated not
just by china but also
larger institutions like the world
health organization that don't even
recognize it as an official country
but another thing to really consider
here is is that also you know it's it's
not too late it's not over because china
also has their own problems
uh when we look at their financial
systems it's in
it's it's it's just as fake and
artificial as the united states when you
look at
their their huge population of men when
you look at their natural resources when
you look at the problems that they have
within their own empire
you see something that is not as strong
as the united states right now which is
something important to highlight there's
one thing i have to say about that is
that
we did this in terms of like we gave
china the money
we gave the chinese communist party the
money to be able to build themselves up
we built their
uh surveillance system yeah we built the
great wall cisco built the great
firewall for
the china party amazing um you know we
like
like mit researchers have given them uh
dna sequencers to like
places involved in organ yeah and like
that the dna sequences are being used in
xinjiang to like monitor the weakers
but i think like the mistake we're
making now is giving them more money
um the didongshin thing that you talked
about most people have seen like the
seven minute version or like some of the
clicks where he talks about
biden and things like that but the full
18 minute speech that he gives
most of it is actually about u.s china
decoupling
economically and how you know he was
like
the u.s china should decouple but why
are we inviting
um you know wall street to come in and
buy our bonds why are we inviting
them to come you know establish their
companies in
in china it's very smart and i'll tell
you why we should do this
it's because whenever we you know we go
invest in wall street in
america like we use the us dollar we're
playing
their game because we have to use the us
dollar that's how they can sanction us
that's how they can have a trade war
with us what we should do is invite them
in
and then they're playing on our turf if
you know if they're investing
in chinese bonds and chinese stock
markets chinese companies
then we get to call the shots wow that
was his
speech and i think one of the things is
we don't listen
when they tell us what they're going to
do they've been very transparent but the
this is this is true
of many communists even here in the us
they often will
scream exactly what their plans are and
the american people kind of just roll
over and ignore it yeah is this why
blackrock is getting involved in china
now
yeah i mean they're being promised that
like
you know china because black rock is
thinking china has 1.3 billion people
yeah we get our mutual funds in there
you know our pensions our bank accounts
our money american money is in blackrock
it's one of the biggest
asset management firms in the world
we're talking about trillions of dollars
and now they also are getting bailouts
by the federal reserve but they're now
working with the chinese
americans are interested in ways they
don't even know
larry fink the ceo of blackrock last
year made a speech
at like a big gala dinner for this u.s
china
association that was uh and he was
talking in front of kenyan kissinger
um in front of the chinese ambassador
about how great china was
and you know they've it's so great that
they've lifted so many people out of
poverty
um you know praising them using like
china prop chinese propaganda stuff
and then saying but like you know what
there's still a lot of people who need
help in china
and you know blackrock can you know we
can go in and we can
you know provide that type of support
for
uh you know the chinese people and help
them make more money
using our services and you know who else
is really invest in blackrock
uh comcast which owns
nbc msnbc which also has not really been
reporting much on the whole
eric swawwell phong new york times
didn't even cover it
i say technically with my very good
chinese pronunciation it would be a fong
fong
does this play into the global reset for
for for greatness
great reset we actually have somebody on
our team working for our other show
america uncovered
uh working on an episode about the great
reset kind of looking what they're
saying
it's actually weird how well i'm
repeating what he has told me
but uh that in like the actual speech
it's very vague what they're talking
about it's just like kind of
ideas but nothing specific which is very
resetting global capitalism
yeah yeah but what is what does that
mean redefining
capitalism for fairness and of course
equality
what it means is giving money and power
to massive multinational corporations
that's what it means
and then they can bring that money to
china oh absolutely yeah
there's money to be made i got a
question is the gutter oil stuff true
you know about gutter oil
oh uh yeah that was definitely something
that was happening inside of china
wow do you want to explain to people
what the gutter oil thing was
what was it was people were i think vice
did a documentary about that's why i
learned about it
so they were basically taking used oil
and kind of from the sewer right from
the sewer
and then straining it and reusing it
yeah as
they were videos yeah i couldn't quite
stomach
often we make the other member of our
team matt yeah
do the watch the things we don't want to
watch we made him watch the hunter bite
and sex videos oh no oh geez
i think we scarred him for life yeah
well so so i saw those
i remember watching a video about this
gutter oil and what was happening
people found essentially free so they
would take
you know scooping devices of some sort
and go into the sewer lines and scoop
out refuse
and then strain the oil out of it boil
it and then use it to cook food and sell
street food
and people get sick from it guaranteed
because it's my understanding is that it
wasn't even necessarily food oil
it was just oil so they might be using
oil from you know
spilled out of a car or something and it
mixes in they boil it down and they cook
with it
people eat it the chinese communist
party just like blew up any kind of rule
of law
within the country and so it just became
really horribly corrupt i think the
gutter oil thing
too is like one reason why chinese
people don't actually trust
a lot of the food in china it's been
regulated now so i think it's not as big
of a problem as it was a few years ago
but um i don't know if you know about
like the milk powder scandal that
happened no
milk powder scandal um these babies were
having like
weird deformed heads and stuff like that
and it turned out that like
these farmers were putting melamine like
the plastic
melon like melanin to make the protein
levels look higher
somehow like whatever test they were
using for protein
like melamine could fake the protein
level so they were buying kind of like
extra melamine shavings from factories
and
putting them in the milk and it was
making babies really sick and killed a
few
of them kidney stones like problems
and they first of all covered up this
whole thing because it was happening
right before the olympics
so they covered up this for as long as
they could and then it kind of broke
right after the olympics happened
and then chinese people were like
outraged they executed the head of
china's food and drug administration
because someone had to take the fall it
also created a lot of tension between
mainland china and hong kong because as
chinese people knew about this they
started going to hong kong
in mass to get baby powder baby
same with australia and new zealand they
started like chinese people would go
buy like formula and stuff from
australia new zealand in bulk
so that you could not actually get it if
you wanted it for your baby in australia
i remember being in hong kong
and being like why are all these people
walking around with suitcases and why
is there no baby formula anywhere and
why are they buying it up
all the time and and then that story
broke and it was a huge controversy but
you see a lot of these kind of stories
with fake meat with fake fruit
fake vegetables what are some of the
most shocking ones that haven't made the
headlines in the united states that you
guys picked up on that really raised
your eyebrows
to say holy cow this is crazy
hey specific food well the thing that
comes to mind it's not quite that but
um just thinking of covering up
everything that's happening with the
coronavirus
yeah essentially happened with sars
uh it was the same thing uh outbreak of
the disease they tried to cover it up it
spread around
and actually this is the main reason why
taiwan has done so well with the
coronavirus is because
they suffered really badly from sars so
they they basically established a team
that like was permanently set to like
monitor
the outbreaks of infectious disease
within mainland china and so
back in december they were already like
raising warning flags about
hey something's kind of spreading around
maybe we should be on guard
whereas the rest of the world being very
uh financially invested in china
uh did not have uh was was not paying
any attention to that
uh that's not quite as exciting as milk
but uh i got i got a photo i googled the
photo of her
i've got her oil oh i've seen this is
crazy it's a woman and she's got it's
like
a long stick with this like it's a big
ladle basically
yeah and she's got a bucket she's
pulling sewage
it's she's lifted a sewer cap up and she
is pulling
sewage out and they were filtering it
boiling it and
serving it to people wow
you know i think back to the days of
snake oil in the wild wild west you see
this is why i'm kind of a liberal and
i'm okay with the regulation because i
you know i know the story about the the
cuyahoga river
the you know the fire burst and the
river and we got to you know clean up
our water clean up our environment
this is the kind of stuff that
nightmares are made of when it's just
unrepentant it's just corrupt it's just
power by any means necessary
yeah actually that makes me think of
what was it up in sinclair the
the was it the jungle the jungle yeah
yeah but probably that picture does more
than like anything we've talked about
like just look at them look at gutter
oil from humans
no it hits you in your stomach yeah i i
yo yeah i remember it's it's there's a
video from radio free asia i think
going back to 2013 or so where they show
the process of making this and that
that's crazy to me
yeah i mean i think they've they
realized that that was like a really
bad pr thing for them but there's
probably a bunch of things like that
still going on to this day
we just haven't learned about yeah well
there's the wet markets that the chinese
government said that they were getting
rid of because it could have been
potentially where the coronavirus came
from
and now the wet markets are back right
now which is another important aspect
that people need to understand yeah so
well so this is this is important can
you guys break down what the wet markets
are
i mean largely it's like just a normal
kind of
outdoor market play a critical role in a
lot of people's lives
because there's not like in terms of
like the food supply chain a lot of
people actually
buy food from the wet markets is it just
it's like what like they have
meats and foods out on like yeah yeah so
like a lot of it
is most most of it is just vegetables or
like meat or whatever
some of it is like living animals so you
like in china a lot of poultry markets
they're like live chickens or whatever
and then you
get a chicken they'll kill it for you um
but then some of these wet markets have
like weird exotic animal stuff
like bats pangolins or
yeah like different i think because
people were first saying that like the
wet market and wuhan didn't sell bats so
but maybe it
went through to a pangolin basically but
like
there are and there was like a famously
like a picture going around of like a
board
at from this web market talking about
like how you could get like crocodile or
like
all these different like exotic animals
but like that's not
like that's kind of like not most of
what
what markets are so wet markets are kind
of necessary for their
like for chinese people to get food yeah
but the
food but like the kind of like exotic
animals like living exotic animals and
stuff like that that's where you
the poultry too um that's been a problem
with
like avian flu in the past so that's
where you kind of get into the trouble
where
like weird diseases could come up hey
wouldn't it have been nice if there was
an independent investigation into the
origin of the coronavirus
yeah sure i was going to ask you guys
where what do you think happened because
the official story according to the
uh the communist government is that this
was the wet market there's some people
speculating that this was because of the
gain of function research that was
happening at the woohand laboratory
there's other people making up other
theories what do you guys happen
what do you guys think happened uh
specifically with china
well specifically in leaked internal
documents from
the world health organization showed
that they made a deal not to investigate
the origin
wow right the web market
was like they don't say it's the wet
market anymore like actually what
they're trying to do
is blame every other country they can
instead yeah
they're saying australia right it came
from australia from italy it came from
italy
maybe it came from frozen food that was
imported into china like
they're just trying to they don't even
say it's the wet market anymore
uh i mean i think at first i thought
well it's pretty
likely it did come from a wet market
because that's what's happened multiple
times with bird flu
right and sars was a similar situation
but um you know it seems that there have
been
earlier um outbreaks than what was
associated with the wet market outbreak
so it's not really clear anymore they're
covering it up and this is the reason
why they're going so hard against
australia now
well one of the reasons are going
against australia but they were asked
they were demanding an international
independent investigation
make sense and they hit australia hard
i i was reading about the spanish flu
the 1918 uh flu
uh pandemic please don't call it the
spanish flu it's you know
diseases happen everywhere you should
you're right you're right you're right
i'm sorry
well uh interestingly there's a there's
several theories about where it actually
came from
and so the two leading theories it
actually wasn't spain
it was uh it came there was there was
world war one basically and you had
a lot of people were in the trenches
they were dirty they were sick they were
injured so when they came back to the
u.s they were bringing it with them
and it actually started to mutate and
expand and get really really worse a
whole lot worse in the u.s
but uh some have said it came from china
and
the evidence for that they say is that
china did not experience they didn't
get hit hard by the the flu pandemic and
the reason they think
is that it originated in china as a
weaker strain
the chinese people gained a herd
immunity to it
it made its way to you know through
europe to the u.s and by the time the
mutated strain had come back to europe
they already had herd immunity to
that similar strain so they were less
impacted by it oh interesting it's
interesting to even you know go back a
hundred years
now there are academics who are saying
you know especially chinese economics
saying that's not true you're lying you
know
it was you you're dirty and things like
that i had a moment where it was like
100 years ago wasn't 1918.
um but uh just what are you doing
uh yeah just uh china back then was also
an entirely different
yeah that was before the communist
revolution right
yeah and i think an issue people
sometimes have is like they conflate
all of china's five thousand years of
history to what the communist party is
doing now right right
which is which is grossly inaccurate the
chinese communist party is you know
communism is a western ideology that
came to china
and basically it's the dark ages
wasn't that didn't something happen
where they melted down all of their like
uh
plowshares and greatly the greats
that's where they did that what was that
all about why did they do that well so
mao wanted to
increase uh steel production and so
there was this insane thing where just
everyone like everywhere like in
hospitals and schools they were all
melting down metal to make steel and it
was
not like steel you could use it's called
what was it
steel yeah pig iron that's it yeah and
like it was completely useless you can't
make a walk into like
steel beams that you can use for
anything yeah and because it was like
this you know
top-down state mandated thing farmers
like had to keep up production and so
they like there were issues of them just
like using their
farm tools and then
starved there was many reasons the
famine happened yeah
from the uh sparrow campaign where they
killed all the sparrows because they the
sparrows ate the seeds and so you got to
kill all the sparrows
the sparrows also ate the locusts the
the culture revolution was when they
started purging
all of the traditional that came after
yeah yeah so so
can you explain the culture evolution
mao basically it felt that he was losing
control of the party politically
so he um announced that like the party
had kind of lost its way
that like the party was becoming to
bourgeois so they needed a cultural
revolution
within the communist party to kind of
purge the party of counter-revolutionary
elements
and he gave power to the red guards
which hadn't
existed before they're kind of these
groups of like young people who are
you know basically worship mao so he
basically used the red guards to
um so he could take power from the
people that he felt
in the political system who were trying
to like take
he was also very paranoid so he felt
that they were trying to take power from
him so
he used the red guards to basically uh
cause chaos in society and like there
are different factions of red guards and
they would fight each other in the
streets
um you know like the whole chinese
society ground to a halt essentially
it's kind of hard to like talk like for
anyone who wouldn't live
through the cultural revolution to kind
of like get the real flavor of it i've
heard described from
chinese people who lived through it like
we went crazy for 10 years
yeah i mean it was really much worse in
the beginning and then towards the end
it kind of started to peter out a little
bit more
my parents were both alive during the
cultural revolution and
um they would talk about it but like
they wouldn't really talk about
like all the bad things that happened
for a long time and then they started
when i was like a teenager
actually talking about like my mom said
she watched
the students in her she was in
elementary school she watched other
students
tie her teacher up wow and beat her
what because like you know any authority
figures
were considered like you know possible
counter revolutionaries or there were
different
phases of it where like you could be a
writer or you could be a counter
revolutionary
you could be like like you could be like
there could be a lot of things that like
unfamiliar you know
yeah well definitely you know you could
be a like if you were a fascist
you if you were you were like oh you you
might be related to a landlord like if
your
family used to own land before the
communist revolution
then you were you know like you're like
a black
force like there were all of these kmt
at one point
how many people died during this period
and do you see any parallels with what's
happening culturally in the united
states
i well i do think the cultural
revolution like
nazi germany is a point in history that
like we should all
learn something from because how a
society gets to that point it's
it's it's something we all need to be on
guard for because
it was people were killing pain are we
are we on track to that point
well so for example like one of the like
people would call like somebody a
counter-revolutionary
and like i think it was nobody really
knew what that meant it was just like
that's the bad thing
yeah like analyzing or yeah or like how
some people use far right what does that
mean
right alt-right you had people spying on
each other
you had like neighborhood committees
that were set up specifically to
watch whether anybody was getting out of
here it's had to be afraid of their
children
you had children who like children were
taught in schools to
like spy on their parents to see if they
were counter-revolutionary and
you know you had people who actually
denounced their parents to the red
guards and the red guards killed
their parents and they thought that they
were doing the right thing
that's creepy stuff well we all know
about you know germany
during world war ii but when you look at
the lives lost
then and when you compare it to the
chinese cultural revolution and the leap
forward it's it's
insignificant uh what are the estimates
what are the numbers because i know
there's a lot of debate specifically
going around how many people passed away
during this period of time what do you
think it is well it depends on who you
listen to
for example uh according to the chinese
communist party the great leap forward
there was there was no great famine
that caused there was a couple years of
bad weather no it was it was called the
you know it was like three years of
natural disasters yeah
so it was like it wasn't mao's fault you
know it wasn't the party's fault it was
totally a man-made disaster
but like if you listen it's like you
know years of natural disasters like it
wasn't our fault
um the cultural revolution they don't
want to talk about
even now right after mao died they
admitted that he was 30
wrong but 70 right and then they blamed
it on his wife in the gang of four
so they basically found other scapegoats
that they could use so that they could
still use mao as like the great helmsman
and that gives you an idea of how bad
the cultural revolution was the party
does not admit any
wrongdoing wow and it was so bad that
they were like okay maybe mal was not
like 100 on the ball with that and but
it was his wife mostly
so i have a i have a friend uh i
mentioned i have a friend in ukraine and
she was telling me how
uh when i was at her apartment it's like
these old soviet communist bloc
buildings that neighbors who would have
disputes
the easy way to resolve a dispute was
they would just call
you know the police and say my neighbor
is saying is bad-mouthing the party
and then the next day the apartment
would be empty and the person would be
gone off to the gulags
rocks i know a story kind of similar uh
from somebody i spoke to who lived this
in china like
uh again top-down government regulations
there mao said there was a specific
number
of percentage of the population in each
area that would be
counter-revolutionaries uh and it would
need to be purged
so there would be meetings where like
the local people like the they have to
decide who is the who is the
witch basically and what it was is like
it would they would just wait until like
the first person had to leave to go use
the restroom
and that was that was him it was him my
grandfather actually got
arrested in china not during the
cultural revolution this was
you have to understand that the cultural
revolution was the biggest and worst of
these political campaigns but they never
stopped
like you know organ harvesting of falun
gong yeah since the chinese communist
party
came to power in 1949 in the 50s there
was the anti-writers movement there was
the
100 flowers campaign where mao was
basically like
i'm going gonna let 100 flowers bloom
please come criticize the party so we
know how to do better and then they
basically rounded up uh and imprisoned
and killed all the people who criticized
the party
yeah uh you know so then you have the
the great leap forward the cultural
revolution
there's a test yeah they're in the 80s
yeah they did
in the 80s there were things like um my
my grandfather was arrested during one
called the anti-spiritual pollution
campaign
which was like the too many western
elements are coming into china we need
to like
purge spiritual things you know what i
would do
i'd be like i i have a criticism the
chinese communist party is too good
it's just too good that wouldn't work
it's too good in the cultural revolution
that's a good criticism there was this
movement where i forget which country
was but somebody
gifted mao mangos it was um
pakistan okay pakistan and mangoes were
like totally unheard of in china at this
time
and so then there became this cult of
people worshiping mao's mangoes
no i remember this because what happened
was oh i don't remember this my father
remembered this he told me the story
many times like
he remembered yeah he remembered it
because um the
prime minister of pakistan gave mao this
like mangoes
mao gave them to the people like he went
to like a particular factory and were
like the workers in this factory should
get the mangoes and the workers at the
factory were like
mao gave us these mangoes we cannot eat
them like let them become
like symbols of his like love for the
people you know
so then they literally like paraded the
mangoes around the country
there are propaganda photos where it's
like the mass of people and somebody
holding up a plate of mangoes there is
literally a propaganda movie where
they're marching down the street with
mangoes
uh it was a huge parade of people and
then like
take a look at this the cult of mangoes
look at this there's paintings of
someone holding up mangoes and his
little trophies
yeah they would make crazies they made
these like fake
mangoes miraculous mangoes oh that's our
episode
yeah that is yeah yeah so they made
these fake mangoes that they then like
brought around to all the different
places in china and were like look at
look upon mao's mangoes and my dad went
when they came to his village
to like see the mango and he remembered
like everybody was
so excited to see the mango that came
from mao
and then later he realized it was a
plastic mango
because obviously the mangoes wouldn't
have like lasted that long but at the
time everybody
really believed that this was one of the
mangoes like from mao personally
yeah and in in that episode we talk
about a story of where like one guy
who was like oh it looks like a sweet
potato they executed him
oh man well let's be honest if there's
one thing that communists are good at
it's sending people to jail and killing
them so at least they're good at that
they're really good at killing people
yeah great 100 million or more
than that yeah well it's interesting we
were talking to somebody about you know
oftentimes people will say oh well you
know
they're great technocrats there in china
and
and that's actually like a horrible
thing to
to it's what it is is like they have
these soulless
solutions to problems like if you have
too many
falun gong people you need some organs
simple technocratic solution take their
organ sell it
it's become huge business there you go
and then i think the thing with us
admiring the technocratic ability of
china like when you see
in the wall street journal or the new
york times they're talking about like
you know china's technocrats that build
these like huge skyscrapers and these
like
which are not just gdp scans you know or
high-speed rail which they stole from
japan
like all this kind of stuff and like we
admire that
um in a way and like we're like being
this this way technocratic is good
um and then we don't it's like taking
the morality out of it because if you
don't talk about
you can't say genocide if you talk about
genocide
then you have to kind of grapple with
what is actually happening in china well
maybe we shouldn't be doing business
there
well another aspect that kind of really
worries me with the technocracy is the
development of
artificial intelligence which we know
china is
rapidly working on with some of the
biggest corporations in the world
how do you see this kind of race which
vladimir putin has kind of
described as building the next nuclear
weapon
which he described artificial
intelligence as specifically
in relation to china well it's not just
it's not just ai there is this bigger
problem of
china the chinese communist party
obviously has no moral regulations
on things so they're able to invite
scientists from around the world to come
to china
and do uh we spoke to a geneticist about
this
they can do any get this this is getting
into alex jones territory yeah
uh congratulations for not being banned
for having him on twice
um but yeah they can they they offer
scientists and businesses from around
the world just unlimited sums of money
to do whatever
and uh you know because there are no
privacy laws in china
these big tech companies can have access
to data that would be
illegal in like the united states you
know the best organ transplant
breakthroughs in the past decade have
come from china wow
oh but because people don't believe that
the forced organ harvesting is happening
there even though there is copious
amounts of evidence that this is
happening
for example uh i remember this
specifically the kunming kidney disease
center
had a promise that if the first
transplant didn't work
they would keep doing them until it did
work and wouldn't charge you and if you
know anything about transplant it is
impossible
to have like a bunch of kidneys lined up
yes yeah there was a story yeah
there was a story that broke this summer
where a chinese woman who lived in japan
um had to go back to china this is a
heartwarming story
for a heart transplant it took them
three hearts
before she got one that she could like
that worked
and like it was like it was it was
actually like
you know portrayed in chinese state-run
media as this great
thing that like she was the you know the
country cared about her so much the
party cared about her so much that they
brought her from japan
and they gave her hearts until it worked
you know
and they accidentally admitted that they
had you know
this like oregon bank of prisoners or
whatever we you know at least i've
laughed at some pretty dark things but
it's the sheer absurdity
of how awful it is and it's just
keeps happening it's been happening i
mean how the the the the
in the insane stories that we have go
back what to what when when this all
start happening in china
which specifically are you talking just
like the the communist party oh the
communist party was doing insane things
uh even before it
successfully conquered china we we have
stories going back
you know how many years is it now is it
80 it's it's it's 100 years
since the party really yeah 100 years of
the most psychotic things you've ever
heard and it's only getting worse it
seems
with new technology being given by the
west
yeah and we sit here today and
you know how long are these concentra uh
concentration camps been going on
at least since what 2017. well if you're
talking specifically about the uyghurs
probably since 2015 they really started
to round people up
falun gong before that falun gong in
1999.
yeah and that was like black jails or
just the prison systems
uh military hunters we were supposed to
uh
you know never let something like this
ever happen again
you know the people of the world we've
let it happen twice within the last
20 years right right and and disney's
clapping for it oh yeah and the and how
many users does disney plus have like
100 something million or whatever
and then the head guy is going to become
the ambassador to china yeah i think
he'd be a great ambassador
but we're watching all of this happen we
know it's happening
and for some reason it's just gonna keep
happening well the media has completely
failed on the story of organ harvesting
uh that
you only really started to see any
reporting on
organ harvesting uh in the past year
after
a group called the china tribunal which
was led by a guy named sir jeffrey nice
who oversaw the
war crime trial of slovenian milosevic
they spend like a year they spent like a
year looking into it and
like ruled like this is definitely
happening this is not a conspiracy this
isn't something being made up
and they're in this tribunal there was
an interesting story
where a former new york times reporter
d.d kirsten tatlow
uh was in china she said she overheard
officials talking about or
it was two doctors she was at like
she was doing stories about organ
harvesting but not related to the forced
organ harvesting related to the idea
that china was going to start using
organ donors
and and then she said okay she was at a
dinner with these two chinese doctors
and like they were talking about this
like
the fact that the chinese government had
said they're no longer
going to use prisoner organs and then
one of the doctors said to the others
the other we can't use prisoner organs
and the other doctor said no
and then the other doctor was like what
about prisoners of conscience
and the other doctor was like no can't
use those anymore either
and then she overheard she heard them
say this in front of her and then she
went to her editors and was like at the
new york times i would like to
look into this forced organ harvesting
thing because i think
you know there's i heard overheard this
conversation
there's something weird with the numbers
like i would like to look into the story
and she was
discouraged from looking into the story
she was told
is there really anything new here also
you know the people who
talk about organ harvesting are on the
outer fringes of advocacy
yeah like a nice way of saying that
these are only like crackpot conspiracy
theorists people who believe in this
and so she was about discouraged from
looking into this
the new york times still has not covered
the tribunal as far as i've seen and
then
um basically she also thinks that
bringing this up
uh was one of the reasons she didn't get
a promotion later
because her editors like were so upset
about this
it's how the game has played these media
companies don't rock the boat we want to
make we want to make money so it look
you know especially right now in media
one of the one of the stories we covered
the other day is that cnn's president
jeff zucker is
probably going to quit i mean he's
thinking about it you know they say it's
because he's having a
a bit of a fight with his boss but come
on no trump no ratings they found a
really really easy path that was only
somewhat controversial you're not going
to make any of your
advertisers angry you're not going to
make any any foreign countries angry
you're not going to risk your
circulation in certain places if you
just rag on trump 24 7 you'll make money
easiest path to cash no no real
journalism required
and that's what we ended up with well so
this is great if they
collapse that means people will only
have tim cast and china and sensor
i think that's uh well i think i think
what's going to happen interestingly
these media companies have were on the
verge of death before trump
when trump came in it gave them
something to do now i think we're going
to see
some kind of rebalancing between
mainstream narratives
and independent media so what this means
i guess ultimately is that independent
channels will have much more influence
in the news cycle
the new york times has been doing really
really well
cnn and msnbc and the networks are going
to collapse and that means
those airport news channels won't have
that that power so
this could be a good thing so maybe it's
not not over entirely
but i do think seeing the you know i
think that the democrats are going to
take georgia
uh trump's not on the ticket and for the
senate for the senate right
without uh donald trump on the ticket
trump supporters are not going to back
mitch mcconnell and the republicans
the republicans certainly will trump
supporters are telling mitch gtfo
so if the democrats end up taking
everything and we have a president who
is
in my opinion you know compromised by
china but at the very least we'll call
him sympathetic based on the people you
mentioned that he surrounds himself with
i think china is going to get carb
launched they're going to do what they
want and u.s won't stand in their way
if anything u.s is going to help him the
new york times just put out a piece
today about how to reset the
relationship with china
yeah and it was full of um advice from
people from goldman sachs and citigroup
huawei and huawei yeah you know one of
the things that sparked the russia gate
investigation was
uh i could be wrong with this but it was
michael flynn i think he was talking to
sally yates and he said
he didn't think russia was our greatest
adversary he thought china was
and that alarm bells oh no someone's
badmouthing china we
we must stop them because everyone knows
it's actually russia yeah biden has
talked about how he views russia as
the bigger threat we have this the
biggest hack i guess in in history
and immediately they knew it was russia
they're calling it a digital pearl
harbor this is what the media is saying
the cyber equivalent of pearl harbor
just happened that's what they're saying
and it was russia who did it now we've
seen no evidence
we've seen nothing to indicate we've
actually been hacked other than they
told us that's what happened
and the many people who work who held
stock at solarwinds the company that was
hacked
sold off a large portion of that stock
just before the news broke so
perhaps something happened but now what
we're going to be marching into or with
russia
over what natural gas i don't know
meanwhile the actual threat
is china and it's seemingly going to be
ignored by this incoming
administration i think the trump
administration is trying to do
especially the state department
uh is trying to do as much as they can
like that
would be hard for the binding
administration to reverse
one of the things about the ai thing
that luke was talking about is
uh after the trump administration
started banning chinese tech companies
from getting u.s
technology like semiconductor technology
the
the chip technology it actually crippled
huawei and zte and a lot of these uh
companies
smics one of the ones that they're
putting on the commerce department
blacklist today
and that's china's biggest chip
manufacturer but they don't have the
technology like they cannot make the
chips as advanced as the us
chips are so it actually has slowed them
down
a lot in terms of being able to develop
these like super computers and things
like that
but on the other hand we had u.s
companies
who were before this completely
like bringing their technology to these
chinese companies like
a few u.s companies got in trouble for
um providing technology to
that was powering this huge chinese
supercomputer center that was
basically running 24 7 surveillance in
xinjiang
well part of the problem is because uh
they think they're doing business with
civilian you know private companies in
china but china has a specific
civil military fusion they call it where
basically
every company private or whatever is
has to help the chinese communist party
so there is no separation between the
party
and private individuals private
companies um
i think the distinctions between
authoritarianism is mostly pointless
when we say communist or fascist or nazi
or whatever the real problem is always
authoritarian because they function in
so
in much the same way we get into
arguments over but was there economic
system based upon
you know no no no that's pointless the
party tells the industries what to do
the party tells the people what to do
it's authoritarianism exactly
and i think the real end risk is not
it's not necessarily that the chinese
communist party is going to completely
take over the world or the united states
as luke is saying the communist party is
actually horribly corrupt it's built on
a very shaky foundation
i think what the biggest risk is if we
don't
stand up now and get more in bed with
the chinese communist party
when it collapses we'll be so tied to
that
that it will just have a ripple effect
we saw what happened with uh
the coronavirus how there was there's
just things we couldn't get
critical scenes yeah and uh like italy
one of the first countries to get it
really badly outside china has a lot of
ties to china
economic ties and also factories with
made
in italy labels that are specifically
done through went there
i went to some of those factories in a
city called prado which is
largely chinese now and there are
sweatshops in the back alleys
exactly so the chinese are literally
importing slave
factories to italy so they could have
made in italy products
stamped wow legally yeah i mean and and
this is one of the reasons why they said
that the coronavirus spread so vastly
and so fast in italy
it was because of this program of slave
workers going back and forth and italy
was the first western country to get
involved in the helton road initiative
and so they were
the government was very reluctant to
criticize we didn't even talk about belt
and road which is a huge
way that they're trying they're kind of
taking over too
yeah and this is also another example of
what uh didong zhang was saying even
this belt and road initiative which is
roughly an infrastructure investment
around the world it still operates in
u.s
dollars so that's a lot of power the
united states still has
but if everything is either u.n or
whatever digital currency the chinese
county party is trying to run out with
then we're going to lose that power yeah
and then the us dollar is going to start
losing
a lot of value and then we start seeing
a ripple effect where other countries
start walking away from it
then we get hyperinflation as the u.s
struggle to pay off its debts by
printing money in quantitative easing
type programs and then we start
shuffling dollar bills into the gutter
figuratively like we saw in weimar
germany and then the people who bought
uh cryptocurrency
and other hard goods will be safe to a
certain degree
are you saying buy bitcoin not
necessarily i think people are obsessed
with it
uh because you know uh it's it's useful
it's valuable and it's scarce and can
only become more scarce
but i always tell people if you think
that we're coming to a point of
hyperinflation where you're not gonna be
able to buy anything
what makes you think anyone's gonna want
your bitcoin if i'm starving and and
dehydrated i'm gonna be like get away
from me and i'm gonna run towards the
guy's got a bottle of water
so i always tell people invest in things
here's here's what i was saying
i was telling ian earlier this earlier
today think about
the most common thing you use throughout
the day and most people use
that is the hardest to produce
whatever that might be i'm not entirely
sure perhaps antiseptics that's kind of
what we're thinking of maybe jazz
smooth jazz is right you know when the
apocalypse happens there's going to be a
hot demand for that smooth jacket clean
drinking water
perhaps but but but you know uh
i think what is hard to produce
extremely important and used on a
day-to-day basis
antiseptics that's the first thing i
thought of uh i don't i don't know if
anybody
at the top of their head could tell you
how to make alcohol anything
like actual like pure ethanol to clean
wounds clean your hands and
and uh you could you could stub your toe
on the woods and lose your foot lose
your leg or die well this goes back to
what we were talking about earlier where
people need to start investing in their
communities yeah the more sufficient
self-sufficient a community is uh
that will be that's huge yep and we
won't be as dependent
on a hostile foreign regime yeah
that will use the power specifically to
like today the news came out that turkey
is taking 20
million doses of vaccines from china and
they also in the same uh like the
chinese day romanian the same
announcement said that turkey also said
that they
you know approve of china's counter
revel like counter
terrorism efforts that shouldn't be
politicized and turkey will not allow
anybody within its borders to
like you know upset chinese sovereignty
and what that means is
they're going after the uyghurs because
turkey has the largest population of
uyghur exiles are a turkic so so uh
i i heard a lot that we get our
medication our medications are made in
china is
is that true like the chinese will
manufacture say amoxicillin tablets
do we still use amoxicillin yeah
tetracycline do they make the
tetracycline
for a lot of the cheaper ones yes um for
expensive pharmaceuticals or like more
complicated pharmaceuticals we actually
mostly manufacture them in the us
but a lot of the cheaper like generic
like what you're talking about
antibiotics
they come from china or a lot of times
the raw ingredients from the for those
come from china
if uh so uh i think we still use
tetracycline right that's a common
antibiotic i think so uh for something
let's let's
let's talk about a generic medication
it's very common when it's manufactured
in china and brought here does it go
through a regular rigorous molecular
analysis to make sure what's in that is
actually what they claim it is
well if there was a situation where they
were actually exporting like
trash that was actually killing
americans they that would be a huge
issue but you look at the strategy of
china
it's not to come in marching with
weapons and shooting people down it's to
subvert
so if they could put something that
let's say there's an ingredient they
could add in a very mic a small dose
let's say we're producing these genetics
that are used
you know maybe by you know a hundred
thousand people per day across the
united or hundred thousand people per
week across the united states
we had an ingredient at a ratio of 0.5
percent which will create a mortality in
the us of 0.1 percent
per you know you you see what i'm saying
i mean it's an
attrition game they've talked about
unrestricted warfare which is basically
war by
other means you don't use troops uh
everything is kind of on the table this
is what this is what they were talking
about
drug warfare is on the different warfare
right so so a lot of the drugs
in the us are made in china and shipped
here like hard illicit drugs
that that kill people where is the
fentanyl the opioid i think
that's a huge thing and you know they
have total government surveillance but
they somehow don't know when factories
are sending fentanyl to the us
or technically through to mexico which
then so brings it to the us
they know there's connections to the
mexicans i wonder if
uh you know if it's something that i can
think about the top of my head
certainly the chinese communist party
has had meetings where they're like can
we add something
at a very small dose i would go on
notice these medications that would
create a mortality rate negligible but
or unnoticeable but not negligent but
not negligible to to us
i think that would be hard for them to
do but i wouldn't say that they wouldn't
try to do something like that but um the
danger is
in that being discovered and the
backlash being so because like you look
at what they've done with the
they tried this whole mask diplomacy
thing a few months ago where
they were like oh we are going to send
masks like
you know kn95s for the coronavirus to
all these different countries around the
world
and tech and tests and they were you
know and there was a huge backlash
so that was bad for them to have like
the quality thing
so if it's like if it if it's like oh my
gosh drugs from china
are faulty then that would be worse for
them what if nobody noticed
well i think the point shelly is making
is that that's still a risk of being
exposed versus like all the other ways
that
they are very successful at subverting
the united states
like just just buy off wall street or
buy off the incoming president you know
you know they start or go after his
crackhead son
yeah i mean that's that like they'll do
they definitely target
family members of politicians they
definitely target they
they'll target like small-time mayors or
you know state senators yeah we just
heard that
yeah no one like they'll try and even
even even the most
insignificant politician you could think
of could be sleeping with a chinese spy
like somebody who has no merit or value
to the political system
maybe a congressman from california
don't be looking one with blonde hair
yeah who farted on camera once you get
even a great man like rudy giuliani
farted on camera oh that's
true yeah yeah he did and my oh man do
you see when he blew his nose
and then wiped his face or giuliani
i didn't see that yeah the congressmen
were talking about was swalwell who was
banging the chinese spy
and uh yeah allegedly well actually i
don't even know if that's allegedly
anymore well that wasn't in the axios
article i think that was like a
later later accusation he's not denying
it
no that's important to understand here
but one thing that you brought up that i
think is really worth considering is
china's relationship with other
countries
you specifically brought up turkey but i
really wanted to talk about russia
because there's many
official and unofficial alliances that
they have with russia
which again now biden is kind of
pointing as the main geopolitical foe to
the united states but
we also have to understand
geopolitically on the world stage
russia and china have always been
together especially when it comes to
significant moves against the us dollar
and especially when it comes to
countering american foreign policy like
with iran
syria iraq they get involved
and they work together against u.s
interests together so
how do you see this kind of working out
if the united states pushes towards a
bigger conflict with russia how do you
see china
being involved in that well i think a
year or two ago xi jinping actually gave
putin a friendship
medal you can look it up it's very nice
oh was it like a heart and it was like
half the heart
it was like it was big yeah like
like all these medals all the way down
it was insane
they do these weird things where like
she will go to russia and have like
caviar or putin will come to china and
they'll like have putin make a dumpling
and they um they last time xi jinping
went to
russia they had like xi jinping's
favorite ice cream remember this
oh yeah yeah that like the last time
he'd come to russia he'd like said this
ice cream is great so they had like
buckets of this ice
which is why trump gave xi jinping the
best chocolate cake
ever remember that when he went to
mar-a-lago it was the best cake
but i think in terms of china and russia
they won't always stand together against
the us
even if they do kind of hate each other
they do kind of hate each other
you know that that's the whole nixon
thing where he was like well they're
split so
um but like they won't always stand like
in the u.n
in any international body they will
unite to stand against the us
but they're also doing uh sharing of
technology and sharing of
uh their military with specific drills
that they conduct
together as they're you know working in
cohesion many times as well which i
think is
something significant that we should
really also look out for as well
i mean but the chinese military is also
working with the canadian militaries
yes they are yes wow justin trudeau the
prime minister who
said that he worshipped and and admired
the chinese government for their
efficiency to be able to turn the
economy on the dime
is now officially training chinese
soldiers in canada
right now well that actually began in
2013
under the conservative party wow uh what
was the guy named harper
yeah it does it doesn't matter the these
political parties i don't know much
about canada but i tell you the
republicans the democrats
oh yeah this was a sailing of
republicans and democrats bush messed it
up clinton really messed it up
bush it's part two messed it up obama
messed it up
and so i trump kind of went from well i
don't i don't know if trump
did good or or did well
if i'm but hold on you see chyna was
like we can't tell what this guy's doing
he's crazy and meanwhile trump was like
going like
like moving in random directions and
he's like if they can't tell what i'm
doing they can't have a cohesive
strategy against me
well that's what i'm saying i don't know
if trump did well or if it's just in
comparison to everything that came
before it's like wow
amazing yeah like when you're like oh my
god the u.s state department is
actually talking about human rights
abuses in china should that be shocking
like should that really be like wow i
can't believe they're actually doing
something about it i mean the president
has stormed beaches
you know before the president of the
united states can meet with kim jong-un
the insane dictator of north korea but
he can't meet with the president of
taiwan
yeah that's that's geopolitics right now
well how about we go to super chats see
what the uh the viewers have to say if
you haven't already smash that like
button
i see many people have noticed we have
this cool fancy new graphic that says
smash the like button and share this
video
shelly and i have learned that we need
to also encourage people to smash
buttons
well i i think i think people genuinely
are aren't aware
it's like a metric youtube uses for
recommendations it is important yeah and
sharing also it really is a huge help
that's why i think i think they've sort
of tried what youtube has tried backing
away from the like button because they
used to be these videos where like
people would be like let's get 50
billion likes
but they still do it it does like the
more likes it gets the more they'll
share it in the in the immediate so
which is important because of all the
things that youtube has openly said
they're going to do they kind of
hurt channels like your channel like our
channel
so we got a great super chat here from
rudy c winslow he says a cab
are you guys familiar with a cab well
all communists are bad
oh
but i didn't really know that term
communist bandit right yeah but that's a
really old weird term but it's great is
i find it i keep meaning to use it more
so uh eric cecil says my response to
andrew yang's vaccination verification
plan is that maybe we should start with
requiring a driver's license when voting
eddie johnson says i'm so excited that
you have china uncensored but where's
matt
oh matt uh matt is hard at work we've
left him
left and back writing scripts while we
have fun here with you tim being forced
oh interesting here's a good
recommendation man of culture says hey
tim next time get america uncovered on
the show that would be hey
great america uncovered i've heard about
that show and it's handsome host
yeah yes i i you know completely
unsolicited but i recommend you
subscribe
the host who is uh absolutely not you of
course no because because i host china
and censors that's right
yes chuck you farley says tim and luke
should do a tour with special guests
like jimmy dore jason burmes
essai morales etc yeah that'd be cool
jimmy jimmy dore is amazing jimmy dorsey
he's got he had a great rant about
uh the transfer of wealth that's going
on with covenant and stuff and he's a
lefty guy so he's very much for medicare
for all but he's basically
he's pointing out the very important
things that i think doesn't matter if
you're left or right
they're extracting wealth sending it up
to the elites
et cetera and i worked with jason bermus
before he's a great guy but what would
we do
we're going to go on tour and just argue
with each other maybe we get a big class
a camper
we do this we do our our standard
youtube programming from the camper as
we drive across the country
and then do late night as we cancel each
other out by screaming and being too
loud yes
and then saturday saturday or sunday
night we do a special like we're here in
cleveland we're doing a live show and
we'll get a
well you can't do that anymore because
code would lock down so wouldn't work
we'll pull the camper up into a random
park and tell everybody to come and
we'll put the speakers on blast
tai chapman says tim ask about the
chinese india conflict
india is dominating last i heard oh
dominating
that's kind of a stretch uh
gosh that's that's a big topic um so
essentially what china is doing in india
is the same as what it's done in the
south china sea like
salami slicing bit by bit they'll like
go a little bit further on a disputed
border build a base and then like
if you start to fight the territory yeah
yeah
um but india has been great about um now
recently like
banning a lot of chinese apps uh you've
seen india joining
the the quad is the great new uh
alliance that has been coming out
which is an alliance between india the
us japan
and australia interesting and this
basically it began
it was japan's idea like in 2007 2008
and it basically died because no one
wanted to stand up to china
in the past couple of years it's
suddenly come back
so yeah india is definitely on the front
line with the
fight for the chinese counties party and
they managed recently to take back some
territory
that's interesting yeah but china has
things called the string of pearls
uh which is basically them making uh not
militar not naval bases uh all around
the indian ocean just potentially deep
water ports yeah
for you know like in pakistan right
right india's good neighbor
sri lanka yeah daniel maxwell says
in the third world in the third world
third world countries china is doing
exactly what the u.s was doing during
the cold war with the soviet union
the major difference is they are also
trying to buy influence in the united
states and they are succeeding at it
zachary pasquale says chris what do you
think is the biggest
most long-term repercussion for our
country under a biden administration in
terms of our unofficial cold war with
china
well a lot of people are encouraging
biden to do a reset at china reset if
that happens that's
that's bad for us tim said liberal
democracy around the world
i don't know if you want to add anything
to that shelly well basically yeah like
not standing up to china um kind of
letting them
walk all over the u.s yeah like
they if they if we don't do something
about it not just economically but
geopolitically
like if we kind of go back to like
engagement and we'll
we don't want to we don't want to make
them mad that is like the number one
thing you can't engage with the country
with concentration camps and forest
organ harvesting and where having a
brother or sister was illegal
yes correct mitchell says chris and
shelley are great guests their show
led me to your show everyone keep the
good work appreciate it
cliff lee says chris shelly i'm glad you
finally made it on the show thanks for
all your hard work in hong kong last
year
thank you it's it's great to be on the
show i had friends a good friend uh
vince pushed me to get on your show so
oh right on yeah
cool i mean we've been getting messages
all the time recommending you guys
saying you because we always talk about
china it comes up you know
and uh i guess you guys are the experts
i'm happy you guys are here
i'm happy you're here dak 941 says look
forward to the show every night thanks
for all you do two questions
uh what happened to the sig can someone
come by
to skate if properly vetted no need to
be on the show just want to skate
the answer to number two is yes you can
um we have two skate parks we are going
to be doing a vlog
and we are going to be i guess
legitimately a private location but
we're gonna allow certain you know
people to to come hang out periodically
it just depends uh once we get the
proprietary website up
it's gonna be over at teamcast.com we're
getting pretty close to launching it
probably gonna be like a membership
thing so there's going to be like a
platinum tier members
and we'll only have maybe like 10 of
those available and those are people who
can like come and freely you know hang
out
at the park or whatever and it'll be
like a vetted thing for sure as for the
sig
oh man i don't think anybody asked about
that uh
never got it uh with with all due
respect and appreciation to the crowder
team
for trying to get me this sig m400 which
would have been awesome
it got sent to a location too far for me
to actually go get it
and i was in new jersey and considering
the laws of new jersey it would have
been
i would i would just call it impossible
it would have required me to have
cancelled a
you know a portion of my day to drive an
hour and a half
there and an hour and a half back and
then i would have to wait five days
then drive an hour and a half there and
an hour and a half back and that was
just completely impractical so i never
ended up getting it unfortunately
and uh that's that's it no sig so
but they tried i i have no idea what
happened to it i wonder if it just got
sent back or something
so but hey it is what it is you
sometimes you can't cry over a free gun
you didn't get
all right let's see kylo says is the ccp
attacking canada
and the u.s simultaneously is this what
soft war looks like
oh yeah canada is getting hit hard
australia's getting hit hard i would say
it's worse in canada and australia than
it is in the us
that's true because the they're actually
kind of afraid of the us
that's why us is enemy number one uh so
australia and canada they thought saw as
like softer targets
that are weaker which is why they've
kidnapped canadian citizens yeah
basically really
yeah the two michaels michael covered
michael's pepper he's been in china for
two years
yeah basically after canada uh arrested
uh
the cfo of huawei because of violations
on u.s sanctions on iran
china in turn kidnapped two canadians
they were in china they were in china
they were in china but they've
essentially been held without any real
charges i think they've been caught
charged now with spying spying yeah wow
but uh
they've been held for two years now and
basically made it very clear to the
canadian government that
if they release the cfo of huawei then
these two michaels get released
trudeau recently said he's hopeful the
situation will be resolved
hayden says it passed by a while back
with little attention because the news
cycle speed but cocaine mitch's wife
elaine is from a family that runs a
shipping company where the ships are
built in china with funding from the ccp
and ship goods to china elaine secretary
of transportation under trump
yep i was talking about that and sharing
the article right before uh
how the show began and even a couple
days ago when mitch mcconnell came up
specifically blocking uh trump and of
course the election telling the senators
not to challenge it
we were in dc a couple years ago at a
think tank event and somebody brought up
elaine chao and her
and everybody kind of laughed because
everybody knew that
her family had these close ties to the
chinese communist party but also knew
that
washington was going to do anything
about it wow
rita ho says tsmc is a taiwanese company
and recorded number one 53.9 percent
in global semiconductor foundry market
while samsung occupied only 17.4 percent
how would this affect the 3c products
worldwide
when weak biden let china take over
taiwan
everything's going to become more
expensive that's taiwanese
yeah taiwan right now is really trying
to uh mark itself as a place where like
high quality
high tech can be made especially as
they're hoping is people realize that
you can't trust the stuff from china
but yeah i mean tsmc had a problem last
year where they
there were chinese spies found in the
company who were stealing the
intellectual property and bringing it to
china
yeah but um the thing is that
taiwan and you the u.s are both better
at
semiconductor chips than china so if
with the if we can stop china from
getting the technology
it'll slow them down a lot yeah chris
knowl
says on the subject of peaceful divorce
how would this affect
global politics and more specifically
dealing with china i think a split would
only help chennai's ability to assert
its will
on the world what do you guys think uh
yes obviously
if the u.s broke into two different
countries like what are they called the
united states of canada and jesus land
yes
there would be no united states on the
political stage at all treaties probably
wouldn't exist anymore
and there'd have to be all new
negotiations with everyone and who would
even control military bases
i don't even know yeah i don't know if
you guys have any thoughts or anything
um well just uh one thought uh
you know obviously the eu and the brexit
was uh that's a big topic
but uh i think to an extent that was
advantageous to the chinese communist
party that
the weaker the eu gets uh the less that
is a power that can stand up to the
chinese communist party and they are
infiltrating the eu in other ways
particularly through greece
eastern nations but yeah desperate ones
yeah
carl schneider says tim i live in cali
and we got and we all got an emergency
alert on our phones today telling us
emergency alert severe
all bay area counties now under
stay-at-home order
covet 19 is spreading rapidly well there
you go
the good news is the good news is
everybody calm down calm down we have a
vaccine
okay now the vaccine doesn't actually
prevent you
from getting the virus we're not sure
this was i believe it was dr vin gupta
said this on msnbc
you still can spread it to others we we
think and you can't travel you still got
to wear a mask and no we're not going to
be releasing the lockdown
and if there are any uh if there are any
adverse effects
there there's no uh uh
there's no liability to the beginning no
no no no no no no no no they're
liability protection
yeah so it's all on you and so i just
see that i'm kind of like
they've they've they've bungled this
quite a bit can i still
cower at home in fear you can't yes yes
okay
if your mask is on yes and you're and
if you're going to have anything to eat
or drink make sure you know you put the
mask back on in between sips and bites
and in the shower and maybe having a
nurse that is prone to
quote fainting as the official story is
now maybe not have her
the representative to get the first jab
that is kind of weird that is weird
i i was wondering about this because
there's a bunch of stories popping up
about
you know that that drive fear and some
of them are kind of isolated incidents
like we had an anaphylactic
uh response to a medical worker in
alaska one person
and i'm kind of like is that something
that needs to be reported
or is the media trying to just kind of
like scare us
all the time it doesn't sound well
that's one person sounds like the media
but i have to wonder i'm like don't they
want the vaccine and then i realized no
they were the ones claiming trump could
never pull it off they weren't ratings
right yeah so now it's they they chose
the woman who
has a fainting disorder and they give
her the vaccine and then she faints and
the video goes viral or they give an
empty syringe to a guy
that was hard to watch well i think
i think the simple solution we talked
about is he just accidentally reused the
other needle
yeah even worse i saw you saying that
whatever it is whether
it's an incompetence or a conspiracy it
doesn't really build
trust akapot says
with china it's all sun tzu the art of
war know your enemy
the ccp knows this well and their
tentacles are in everything in our
country
russia too but not as prolific we have
adversaries that hate us
collectivists i kind of
want to push back on that a little bit i
don't think people always compare it to
sun tzu the art of war
the chinese communist party was a hard
split from the
the 5 000 years of chinese culture what
uh the tactics of the chinese communist
party are
communist tactics that you've seen used
around the world the way they uh
flip and invert things so i i wouldn't
say
this is a result of sun this is
specifically comey taxes that they
learned from the soviet union and
improved one of those things where we
don't really want to think of china as
like a marxist leninist
maoist country but it is uh and
because like also people like want to
learn about sun tzu and chinese culture
that's so much more fun to study than
like
leninism right yeah yeah jose
pereira says portugal has a 500-year
relationship with china
china has invested a lot of money in
portugal the golden visa scheme
and even talked about china-china
interest in the
lahis air base in the azores
interesting trip to portugal shelley
yeah
apparently balian says alaska has a
crapload of rare earth minerals
some that aren't anywhere else yet all
the hippie-to-be tree lovers up there
don't want us to mine them
in my backyard yeah yep in the meantime
we have these uh you know
environmentalists climate change people
who don't seem to care at all about
china no we need to
work with china on climate change that's
right that's one of the things you know
that's the kind of line from the
engagement people
oh yeah that like we need to work with
them yeah get that paris climate
agreement yeah
lucas oberhauser says really glad you
had chris and shelly on tonight i've
been a big fan of china uncensored for a
long time now
and has been a great way to keep up to
date with what's been happening the u.s
news
never covers it is really interesting
though that it it's good in bed at the
same time
it would be better if we had a media
that told you things that actually
were important across the board but if
people uh
are going to specific sources like you
watch my content and we talk about very
specific things in politics typically
rag on the democrats
and you need a healthy diet you got to
mix it up with something else we don't
really have you turn the news and
they'll give you
you know five minutes of each major
segment anymore maybe that's not even
the best thing
but then maybe people only hear the news
about one thing and
maybe it's better to be more uh
well-versed on single issues than to be
only knowing a little bit about a bunch
of things perhaps
good argument well i'll go either way i
guess sombrero cat
llc says tim you need to have joshua
phillip too he made a great documentary
about the ccp connections with the
election
great show as always we will look into
it
isaac castillo says everyone exclaim
shelley to show appreciation
[Music]
texas ranger says falun gong is a cult
according to my chinese american friend
the people's republic of china is an
evil godless empire bent on world
domination
okay i guess he doesn't like either of
them huh the
the cult thing was actually something
that they managed to use in chinese when
they first started going after
falun gong they didn't call it a cult uh
they called it a
heterodox organization which is anything
like that the government doesn't improve
but cult in english sounds so much
better and snappier and makes people
like hate it yeah like how uyghurs went
from like splittus
to terrorists yes basically
jacob meyer says love you chris and i
watch china uncensored every day thank
you for doing what you do
i don't know how people like me would
ever know what's going on if you weren't
there doing the best damn reporting i've
ever seen
oh hey tim yeah
just the host rayne says i'm so glad you
have these guys on i've watched china
uncensored on and off for years and
hearing them in conversation it helps
helps out a lot of context there you go
very cool
drizzt says obama threw our oath to help
ukraine when russia invaded them
so i'm sadly not surprised about
southeast asia that's a good point too
yeah brewmaster monk says a hot war
would be a useful way for china to deal
with its gender imbalance especially if
they think their liberalization is
inevitable anyways
the one way they actually are dealing
with the gender imbalance is the belt
and road initiative because they can
export all of these young men who are
not like can't find jobs
or you know wives and like you know send
them to africa or
south america and they can go build the
roads there wow
yeah ted says chris i've been following
your show for years
and i've been asking tim in the chats
for weeks to have you on and i'm so glad
it happened chris
shelley tim lids i love you guys and
i've been sharing your content a lot
really appreciate it
yeah what about me
well i i think luke is a great guy
okay i needed that thank you
not good at username says duterte is
making a big mistake ending philippines
relations with the us and getting closer
with china
talk about independency
yeah i think duterte definitely when he
was campaigning he was like
i'm going to stand up to china and then
when he got into power he was
immediately like
the philippines could be another chinese
province
we haven't even talked about all the
horrible things that are happening in
south korea right now
oh yeah waffles sensei says hey tim
don't you think it's really weird that
the narrative was set
so fast to blame russia for the cyber
attacks
could be true but i think in the long
run we will need russia as an ally and
an enemy for the days ahead i believe
trump
understood this too that's what i
thought perhaps i do
think them immediately coming out being
like it's cyber pearl harbor and russia
did it i'm like
okay well we need to have like hearings
or something or some
legitimate news coverage not from
someone i don't trust china has hacked
the us a lot
in the past and we've not yet we've not
done anything about that huh
they're probably hacking us right now as
we speak in in many ways podcast
oh we didn't even talk about zoom zoom
yeah
oh zoom yeah that was a big story that
uh the
department of justice just unsealed an
arrest warrant for like a chinese
zoom executive for literally taking
uh user data from the us and giving it
to the chinese government wow
uh and so that's when everybody was like
zoom is
like it's kind of sketchy because it has
you know all the stuff in china
and the servers in china should we be
worried about it the answer was obvious
yes cameron ham says china's spy list
leaked and two days later our entire
government was hacked and they blamed
russia
it's clear it was china well the hack it
happened nine months ago
and i believe that was under uh kris
krebs who was recently fired by trump oh
he told me it was very secure he said we
had this most secure election ever
and he didn't even realize the biggest
attack had happened right under his nose
yep well there you go jessica says
really enjoy luke on the live show and
very excited for the future content you
have planned keep doing what you're
doing tim i've learned so much to
discover your channels
thank you well thank you for watching
and your super chat helps sustain us
there you go luke yeah bill says yes an
international investigation found
based on spanish sewer samples that
covet 19 was present at least six months
before the fake outbreak
god forbid we use science facts and
reason well i don't know about all that
but thanks for the super chat
well there was some data and suggestions
that this sickness was around far
earlier than you originally thought so
the origin
we still don't know where it came from
we still don't have a patient zero but
magically in six months we have a rushed
experimental vaccine
that's going to fix everything so that's
great
but what we do know is it definitely did
not come from china definitely
of course of course let's see
uh crazy man jack says the sickest thing
i have ever seen was a video of a man
boiling a dog alive prodding with a
stick to keep it in the wok supposedly
they believe the more pain they cause
the animal the better it tastes
please ask your guests why this is a
thing is that a thing
it's well there's overall the chinese
people do not eat dogs that has not
really been a thing
uh except for like in the extreme famine
times in vietnam they do though
don't they well it does happen in korea
yeah and but there is this thing called
like the
was yunnan dog meat dog festival
i forget where it is but then yeah the
specific festival is dedicated to eating
dogs
and they do believe that the the more
pain
it was better it was kind of like a
weird pr stunt by this town
where they were like we don't have
anything we're known for i know we'll
have a dog eating festival because it's
not traditional in china to eat dogs at
all
i always i always thought people were
worried that the fear and pain would
make the meat taste bad
like it would cause chemical imbalances
and like not according to these chefs
well thanks there you go ted 2 says
chris shelly i'm a huge
huge long time fan of your shows of all
your shows i commented repeatedly asking
tim to get you said oh this is this the
same comment is it weird or is it
youtube just doubling it up
many people have the same opinion about
us that's right sebastian service says
any opinion on the rip
on ripple xrp or cryptocurrency in
general
and iso 2002 do you think this fits into
the agenda of adapting digital currency
global capital and maybe even the great
reset and the fourth industrial
revolution
i think bitcoin is going to be worth an
insane amount of money in a certain
amount of time i don't know
the exact time frame there are some
people predicting that when within the
next year or two
of one bitcoin will be three hundred
thousand dollars uh some people are
saying by the end of this year so in the
next couple of weeks we'll see it at 28
000 which is is is easily doable i mean
it's already at 22 or 23. it's been
going on a little bit
uh i do think a bitcoin will be upwards
of a million dollars
at some point just speaking yeah but but
you have to think about it it's not a
bold prediction
the bitcoins can only disappear so i've
i actually had a computer with some
coins on it a long time ago got
destroyed
those coins are gone you can't bring
them back so so long as
there's a finite amount of the coins but
the utility remains and people are
holding it
the more people who want to buy it that
exist but the shrinking supply means the
price can only go up in the long run
unless of course people ultimately just
abandon it because they don't want it i
really don't think
that would be the case because there's
there's a real utility in it in
transferring you know
wealth and value very quickly so i
ultimately think
a bitcoin will be worth more than a
million i mean if if bitcoin remains the
dominant
most you know coin that people have
confident in cryptocurrency
then at a certain point the currency
will
become more and more scarce but more
valuable more people want it
less of it exists the trajectory is just
straight up
if you want to use it for some utility
purpose like if i'm a transfer
you know 100 bucks to luke i don't care
about the value of the currency
i'll buy a hundred worth of 100 with a
bitcoin send it to luke and they'll sell
it all within a split second
so it's almost like a a value protocol
you've been using that with the people
you've been working with in like europe
right
crypto uh well like paying people like
that no
no no no no i just people the people
i've paid have always been just the
regular old way
oh it's like you know paypal or
something who
am i thinking of i don't know but if
someone wants to buy that
the people who are holding it are
essentially holding that service
you know so if you're like i need to buy
some coins sent to my buddy it's like
then the person who has it
can charge whatever they want but you
don't care you're like i want a hundred
dollars worth
okay well i'll give you one you can sell
for one okay so whatever the value is i
think ultimately just keep going up
but maybe not i don't know i think i
think it ultimately will because
it's everything global elites and
special interests want
completely traceable i was we were
talking about this earlier
andrew yang posted is there a way we can
check to see if everybody's been
vaccinated right
i'll tell you what that what what i'm
surprised i haven't already done is a
cryptocurrency
for tracking vaccinations and contact
tracing because think about it
you'll have a public ledger they can see
if you've been vaccinated why are you
giving them ideas
i'm not i don't know because i'm sure
they had the idea already oh maybe not
whatever it's a good idea
uh i mean i mean i think it's it's a
night it's a nightmarish scenario
it's a mass surveillance but if you
think about how contact tracing works
you go to a restaurant they're saying
they're gonna scan your barcode or
whatever
imagine it was all just on the
blockchain everything just you know
i actually think that probably bad for
them that's probably why they didn't do
it they want the proprietary information
tracking all your information knowing
everything about you and not letting
anyone see it
so they don't want it publicly in the
blockchain
all right let's see we got here andrew
scott says chris and shelly
short of sharing china and censor with
everyone we know what can we do to help
fight the human rights abuses in china
limit purchases of products made in
china or something else
we get that question a lot uh i mean
definitely sharing
the episode is good i'm not saying that
just for self-interest but like the more
people who are aware is
it's really important but you know like
study chinese in school get involved in
think
think tanks get involved in politics uh
we need people who know what's going on
in positions of power
i mean that's a long-term thing but yeah
it's pretty important because
you have like 30 years of this
engagement school coming through now
right where
people are still they're going to like
georgetown or you're going to like these
places where all they teach is that
they don't teach about china's uh you
know political warfare or their
unrestricted warfare oh no they teach it
that america is bad
and racist yeah so you you have these
people who are not like
and then they get into positions of
power so it's pretty important that
you know people understand what's
happening even in the military it's an
issue so
join the military i think that you know
limiting things that you buy from china
is a help
sometimes it is almost impossible it's
true
but um yeah i tried to do that whenever
possible yeah
douglas says paul revere award for china
uncensored
oh there you go i like awards lone wolf
says great show tim and gang i used to
play
pub g on pc but had to stop playing
because chinese players would fill n a
servers and use cheats and hacks
ninety percent of banned players were
chinese cheating and abusing the system
in is the ccp way
world of warcraft had a thing for a
while where there were chinese gold
farms do you guys have anything heard
about you guys know anything about world
of warcraft
so uh you're playing world of warcraft
this is back in the day way back in the
day
because things are different now you can
just buy gold for your character through
a system they've created
back in the day you know when i was
playing world of warcraft and like oh
six
you would you go around it's called
grinding you're killing monsters and
then
you get their stuff and you sell it to
the vendors and you get copper and
silver and gold
but some players were rich and they
didn't want to have to actually play the
game to play the game
they wanted the good stuff now and they
needed money to get it so in china
people would play the game and just go
around just
grinding and killing monsters and it was
extremely tedious work
and then you could go on these websites
pay money and then they would mail you
in game the currency
wow yeah video game slave labor yep and
it was it was against the rules
and a lot of people got scammed and
their characters and accounts got stolen
and there were reports where people were
like i was buying gold and now my
account is gone and they destroyed
everything
yep everything you've ever you've played
for your game is gone
kind of exactly what's happening with
american companies going into yeah
that's the name of the game oh wow don
paulson says hi chris is there any kind
of push to create some form of civilian
defense force in taiwan in the event of
a chinese invasion
i love your show the taiwan already has
a pretty
robust military especially as the u.s
over the past couple years have been
selling more and more weapons to taiwan
so it would not be an easy invasion
uh taiwan also has mandatory military
service for
all men yeah they got uh what's his name
not jinyoung the guy we interviewed the
joe rogan of taiwan who said he would
personally fight them
oh uh holger chen that's it yeah
tito latino says and then something we
got a fact check but i'm gonna read it
anyway
august 9 2020 wall street journal us
nsa mentions china trying to hack u.s
secretary of state voter rolls
statement also said that china prefers
that president trump a republican not
win re-election
i believe that latter part is true for
sure interesting
unlicks go says tin cap what if someone
bought btc when it was ten thousand for
one dollar
and spent one thousand dollars do the
math but it's like gold try to buy milk
with it
kind of tough but it's just a story well
i almost bought about 6500 bitcoin
2011. my friend was like don't do it man
it's it's like what is
this was back in the day that this thing
called the bitcoin faucet where it would
give it i think
uh 0.05 bitcoin
for free every like 10 minutes and you
could just like
put in your address or whatever and then
you just get it and so i was like
huh now i have like you know three cents
worth of bitcoin i can't do anything
with and i was like this is dumb
but i ended up ended up with a few coins
on a computer computer got destroyed in
a fire those coins are gone forever
but my buddies my buddy we were looking
at this website and it was like you
could buy it was really hard to buy
bitcoin back then
you had to like directly message someone
and then like physically give them money
and then they would send
send the coins to your address and it
happened almost instantly because the
blockchain was
a lot smaller my friend was like dude
it's worthless you can't do anything
with it it's probably some dude who just
made some
scam online hey give me your money and
i'll give you this number and then next
thing you know
it goes belly up and you lost your
savings and i was like that's a good
point man
you know the technology is interesting
but why would anyone use this
and it's hard to give up your savings at
the time and then i remember it was like
uh
a year later was it like 35 dollars and
i was like how much money would i would
have had if i just bought it oh you told
me how to do it
and we were like i wasn't pulled a
calculator and then
it just gets better every year how much
i think would be 145 million
however people point out dude you would
have sold a long time ago
you would have put in your your five
grand or whatever and then
you know once it hit 20 bucks you would
have danced all the way to the bank sold
it all out for a massive return
and i'm like yeah definitely definitely
because you know it's just a smart thing
to do
like any investment granted if you go if
you were alive today
if you're alive today and you could go
back in time you'd be like never sell
so think about that you know never
selling i remember a couple years ago i
think like 2016
it hit like seven grand and everyone was
like this is ridiculous
it's too high and then it fell down like
three grand
imagine if you bought back then you'd be
very happy
anyway if it goes to a million chris and
shelly thanks so much for hanging out
do you wanna have us shout out your
social medias and your channels one more
time for everybody
yeah you can follow china uncensored on
youtube instagram facebook twitter and
i also recommend that show america
uncovered by that other guy
also on facebook twitter uh instagram
and that one actually has a parlor
account as a website right on and
and uh you can follow me on twitter my
twitter address is
s-h-e-l-z-h-a-n-g xiaojiang
and we also have a podcast called china
unscripted that we're all in
so wow cool and of course you can follow
me on twitter instagram parlor at tim
cast and check out my other youtube
channels youtube.comtymcast
and youtube.comcastnews if you aren't
check out the podcast this podcast
teamcast irl on
itunes and spotify leave us a good
review give us those five stars because
it really does help boost us up in those
rankings i think and uh if you are
listening on those podcasts do it do it
as well
don't forget to like this uh youtube
video and this channel subscribe to the
notification bell
we are live monday through friday at 8
p.m we'll be back monday
and of course you can follow at luke
rutkowski who's wearing a very spicy
t-shirt well
i'm under luke we are change on venmo
instagram cash app twitter thank you you
guys are being too nice to me and
yeah coincidentally again i have another
we are changed t-shirt which is a great
conversation starter which i love to
wear publicly to
bars and to other places where you get
to talk to people which you could get
on teesprings.com stores forward slash
we are change thank you guys and don't
forget to follow at sourpatch lids who
pushes all the buttons
right on everybody again thanks so much
for for hanging out this was a great
conversation and probably have you back
on at some point i'm sure the
conversation around china will get
spicier as time goes on so that was
great yeah
lots of fun and i i can't believe i'm
sitting in the chair that alex jones
said yeah
you are sitting is that why you picked
that side you're like i want to sit in
jones well i can feel the residual
mailbox
michael uh malice left his super male
vitality here
it's just been sitting i don't know what
to do with it so it's just on the table
people are walking you know
whenever whenever someone comes in i go
it's for you actually and then i take it
back michael come get your super male
vitality
well hey instead of worshiping mangoes
we can worship my mouth
let's get a painting of the people
holding it up and um what's the what's
the other one called the brain
blast is that what it is yeah brain
glass only i don't know that's the jimmy
neutron thing anyway
thanks for hanging out everybody we'll
be back monday at 8pm uh and we'll see
you all then bye guys
you